You
Just stairs
Hello, hi everybody who is still muted
She'll undefinite a moment
Hi, hi, I just discovered while I was trying to set up stream that my phone isn't charging. So that's that's great
It's at 20% so if I die
Suddenly halfway through and stop moving. I might have to turn into Muppet mode. I
Don't know
Why isn't my phone charging? Let me try another charger
Hello, hello, oh, you can't hear Fuwa because she's deafened and muted. I'm in a message
I'm good
She's still talking to her chat
I use the six foot cord will it work still not long enough to reach
Okay, this is working it must be the cable
Don't don't ask why I suddenly had a hamster in my arms
I'll probably stream on the weekends
Wait, is it my desk isn't plugged in it does that make sense when I say that my desk isn't plugged in
I don't know why stuff keeps coming
Oh
There she is I was like one day she'll show on mute
All right, I'm good now
Hello, hello
How do you how should should I introduce myself to your stream?
And that would be amazing. I love that. I
Just I never introduced myself. Nobody ever knows gets to know who I am
Hi
Hi, my name is she be cotton bum a violers gen one indulge
And I am your favorite girl failure Dom and I like to do wacky voices and dress up
And do ASMR
Voice range from what I've seen actually it's kind of crazy
I wonder if I could do your voice. I bet if I tried hard enough. I might be able to do yours
I can't do your accent though. That's like my accent. I can't do oh
Yeah, I have a weird like hybrid Australian American accent because it's being online chronically
I
It's like I can I can retire guys you guys can you guys can have her instead. I
Just she just puppeteers the model and I just speak for her. Oh my gosh
I
Anybody's ever done that like a vtuber just moves the model and somebody else
Is because I'm an australian there would be massive like delay
Would be like yeah, hi
Am I actually a skinwalker? Yes. All right, you introduce yourself to my stream. Oh, yeah, right. That's that's true. Okay. Um
gosh
Okay, uh
I'm no good instructions. Um, hello. I am full. Uh, I am
I am full
Okay, that part
Should shut up. I already found you
I need a feed mine
I'm gonna feed mine while you introduce yourself. Um, okay. Okay. Okay. I am full
Uh, I am predominantly a twitch streamer. Um, uh, but I do stream on youtube sometimes and I'm
I'm like, I'm kind of it in between at the moment, but I never do dual streams streams at the same time
I also said I almost did swings
Um, uh, I am an artist. I drew my model as well as most of the stuff that I use
What that's crazy. I do I do I do whatever the heck I want. I don't know. I just mess around to have fun
I can I do whatever I'm okay with anything. I do a lot on stream music, uh
Like whatever I kind of feel like on the day and I'm not scared to do anything
I've even done like IRL walk around streams and stuff like when I visited japan once so
I'm kind of cool with that kind of anything. I just like doing stuff. I love streaming
Unchonically online, please help
That's awesome. Wow you guys you have a very multi talented. Oh, she over here my god
Very impressive. I had no idea that you made your model and a lot of your assets. That's super super cool
I wish I could draw I can't
My audience is nice at any point. Yes, very true very very true
My chat is very happy to see you
Oh my gosh, that would be so fun
Let me pull up your are you straight? You're are you dual streaming on twitch and youtube right now? You said no
No, I never do dual streams. Um
I just kind of like uh, how might put it like I do one or the other
Because I I I don't have the attention span to dual stream
I feel that
I feel that for real. I think I would I would like die. I can't I can barely pay attention to myself and stream
And what I'm doing
I'm gonna I'm gonna pull up your chat so I can see your chat as well
That's a good idea. I want to do that. I want to do that as well. How do I just kidding it saying that I can't
See it. Wait. No, I can't see it
well
Because I don't I don't have a login to
for twitch on my
I'm like hey manager. Um, when am I gonna get twitch access so I can like talk to people
On twitch and they're just like, I don't know
So I just work feelers mostly like youtube, but yeah, they think that they would ever consider like
Like uh
Like giving it I guess a goal to let people kind of do both if they want to I guess I want to be surprised well for um
It's easier when you're in a agency to like pay out your talents on youtube
Um, that's true
And I honestly that's pretty much one of the only reasons besides uh, twitch also being kind of like
Band happy, but um, yeah
They take a bigger cut as well. That's true in an agency that's already like
Having to do extra finances having to be like, yeah, they're taking 50% as well. So
Twitch twitch likes to take money from people
You know, yep as a former twitch streamer. I totally agree with you
Let me pin your stuff in my chat
Yeah, I can I can see I can see your chat now too. Tell fool. We say hi. I can see you. I can see you
She can see you. She's walking. I can read. I can see the hi myself. Hello
I love you almost as well
You're very goofy
I like that though. I like goofy and gremlin. That's that's kind of my thing
You came to the right place too closely. I'm staring
Oh, I'm gonna ignore my travel. You think I'm just gonna read your channel. You guys are cooler. I'm kidding. Oh
Oh my god
Just totally abandoned church
I'm just kidding guys. I'm joking
No, don't leave
Why is apple tv trying to make me sign up for twitch so I can get free apple tv?
Oh, that's like a promotion they're doing at the moment. You can just write it
There's like a dismiss button on it. I know I'm like pressing a bunch of buttons and it keeps popping up
All right. Now I can see
They're gonna leave and go to my street
Sheba, who is sheba? I'm she be
Oh, you have a seimi's cat
Emo just walking away
Oh, that's that's tama. He's actually a ragdoll. He's a ragdoll
I have a cat cam up on my stream. Um pretty often as well
Oh my gosh, like uh on my normal layout. I have like a permanent cat cam in the corner
So you see my cats that pretty often which is why they've got a lot of the molds
I can send you a photo of them actually. I'm not leaving any photo of them. You've seen my cats. Please show me yours
Yeah, I love seeing your cats on your stream as well because they do cat cam too as well
Yeah, yeah, I like having a little cat cam
It's fun
It's a little it's a little level of um
kind of just like
Uh interaction with viewers
Yeah, and then sometimes I'll like give them traits to bait them to the camera
All right, look at the camera look at it goofy
Here's some goofy pictures of them first. I'm so excited. So here's tama
Oh my
It's just another one of tama standing up
I have a picture of fia doing the same thing. Oh my god
Oh my god ragdolls are so cute. It's like a little snowshoe point. Oh, that's so adorable
Here's kama. Here's my other boy. They're they're both very pretty boys
Oh handsome orange boy
Sorry guys, you can't see this stuff. You got to go to fua's channel. Check it out
Check out her check out her twitter. Look for her cat pictures. Yeah, I post photos of them on twitter a lot
Oh my god, I think I got like a more recent one of them. You have so many plushies. Where do you sleep?
Oh, I have like I have like a hundred. Oh my god
But I have I also have a hundred anime figures. Oh my god
I I have a problem. I
I this
It's my life
You know what I I respect you for that
It takes a special kind of lady
To have a hundred figures and a hundred plushies
You know I need my wife who is you know. Yeah, I get that
Wait, okay, so what's this game about?
Uh, it's like it's a puzzle game. Um, oh no like portal and stuff like that. Okay
It's kind of like that but you die more and it's really scuffed and it's really funny
Okay, perfect
I didn't look at anything about this game. You're like, let's play half dead. I'm like bet buys it
I mean, it's really it's really cheap as well. So that's why I really like it. Okay
I think for the money you get you get well more than like two bucks worth of entertainment
There's a new newer picture of combat. He's fat now. Let me see
Oh
My god, that is a big chonk boy. Oh his face. Oh, he's like mother
That was that was a yesterday one where he's begging for treats
Oh, he's like mother watch you take photos of me when I match my lowest points mother
You can't access her twitter link what?
Oh, it's because it okay. Hold on. I figured it out
Oh, yeah, it's because it doubled up. Let me put a space between
La la la la
But the game is pretty simple. I think you'll find it's really funny once we get going
Uh, and it's it's kind of a dead game. So there's like no servers. I mean, there's no
No one's playing this at the moment. I think except us. It's just us. Oh, perfect
All to ourselves
Put a bunch of spaces in between everything so I could be clicked on
Okay, now we're good. I'm just spamming you in my chat
Thank you for the hindry
Yes, I'm just setting up the uh
The the map lobby thingy. Okay the game is I'll explain more once we're in game and I can like show you stuff though
Oh, I just want to make sure it's like pretty easy
I do that on easy difficulty to start with
There's a harder difficulty
Yeah, it goes up to really hard. I think that it's kind of it's like a mix between like doing little puzzles
And it's kind of like I think like
Imagine mind sweeper, but you're like going through each room to see if the room is possible to pass through I guess
Okay, it's something about escaping. I think there's a movie
That this game was based on it's like people in squares and they go through each square trying to escape
But like it's like a horror movie. Oh
But this is not really scary. I think it's like a better horizon, but no, that's not that
Uh
No, it's not that. Um, it's kind of like saw
Oh, okay
Based on it's just like people dying mostly and then it's kind of like a survival game kind of thing. All right
Uh, I I'm so sorry in advance. I am terrible at puzzles
On the lie, I'm I'm garbage as well. So like we can it can just it'll be it's okay because it's funny
It's funny if you're both bad
Okay, perfect. You guys are gonna get a lot of laughs today. I hope you enjoy
Okay, you shouldn't see my if you're gonna multiplayer you should see mine in the servers
Uh, I think the password should be this
It literally says only one person online
That's me
Yeah, not all people play this
Uh, I should see once you're joined and I can start it. I can't see you. It's not popping up
Um, let me put it in Europe. Maybe if I wait, I'll shoot maybe it automatically put me in a different server
I didn't think about that
There's three people alive in Europe alive. Um
Let me see trying to find you there you are
I found you
Which one didn't set it to Australia Australia, uh, I didn't even real they didn't even realize Australia was an option
All right, so me send me the password games. Oh you already sent it to me. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I type in all people see okay
No, they won't
Whoa
Hey, there you go. Okay. I can check I'll start it time to check on the room. Oh, I'm the max about actually
Okay, um
I'll do it in standard no time limit. Yeah, that's better actually no time limits better
Okay, so our eject objective is going to be to like to get to the escape
Five by five, okay
All right, I have like no game sound for some reason
Yeah, I really
Uh, go for it. Take time to see if we can
Let me see if I can meet it on desktop. Did you know maybe well, maybe it accidentally did it
To do to do
Open volume mixer
What the heck it is it doesn't even show that it exists in the mixer
What's happening it might have to do the thing where I wear two headphones at the same time
Well
I mean
I'm sure to remember the audio is important
Yeah, all about the immersion
Uh, I think there's like some rooms we have to listen to a timer or something, but I think it's fine
Okay, I also admit I haven't laid this in like over 10 years. So I'll also after him
Wait say something
It's only doing the game audio
Uno momento
Wait say something
Uh testing hello. Oh yay. Okay
Switching headphones, yes
I'll keep making in-game noises so you can make sure you can hear it
She's just quiet. Okay, I'll turn her up then
One more time
Perfect
I'm not the loudest as well
Now we're now we're ready to rumble. Let's go again
Why am I so short looking why am I looking at your chest
The camera for these models is in like this circle on your on the chest for some reason
So I'm also looking up at you. That's so
Oh, that's not even the most scuffed part. Okay, let me try to remember the controls in this game
So there's like, uh, I think the left shift is to throw your shoe
Left and that's how you can uh, that's how you can like test. Um
Yeah, that's how you'll test if your room is deadly, I think
For me, it's it helps me run
I
What's the alt settings controls? How do I throw my shoe?
I'll throw his g g
Ah, okay. Yeah, I'll make it so you can throw your shoe with g and then so I can like set off traps
throw boot
I'll make it I'll make it z
I
Think you throw that into a room and it might set off a trap that might kill you if you don't
If you don't do that, I think if you die, it doesn't matter that much because I think you just go back to the start
It doesn't even go far
What if I no, you don't have to feel like directly in front of you. Um, is there anything I mean, I'll be honest
Other than just like crouching and and how do you can you crouch? Hold on?
I don't I was trying to crouch with control with it. See action jump
Run, okay. I don't think you can crouch actually I lied
Um, so it's just like
WASD and then like action is e which is how you like use stuff like opening the doors. Okay
Uh, and then you throw your boot if you want now. Um, there is something about the markings
So, um, oh, I lost my shoe
Oh, yeah, I think that's the trap
No, I know I only want you. Yeah, you only get two shoes for the whole run. I think
No, okay. Um, I think if you look at the ground in front of the doors
I think this if I remember this color means the difficulty of the room or if it's safe or not. Oh, I'm getting sucked in
Oh
Okay, so that means we can't walk through that room because I think that one's too dangerous
And I think that one's gone
Uh, do you respawn?
I don't know. I'm
I'm waiting to show up respawn
Maybe it just takes a while. I haven't played this in 10 years. I can't remember
Oh, this room shows us green. So I think mortis is this one safe
Okay, there's like green
Wait, I still can't see you. I'm still not here
I'm still just let me see if I die then. Oh, this is this room safe
I think you think you're supposed to find which rooms are safe and like pass through them
Let me see if I'll die. I'm gonna eat
It was a good run
What's happening here? Oh
And only her shoes
Okay, okay, so I lied dying does matter
Okay, good to know. We're not gonna go. Okay. We'll try not to die. We'll try not to die
It's a race competition who gets there first so you don't respawn someone said
Oh
We don't work as a team. I don't I don't I don't have it set to first wins
I think I just have it set to anyone passes is fine. Okay less of a competition
Okay, so we can uh, we can test this one with my boot
Okay, I think it's good. Nice. No, it has a cool down on the doors. Yeah, what the heck
Okay, this room's safe. Uh, if you look in the top left, see how the room has a little tick
Oh, yeah, it's a little check mark. Yeah, that means it's safe. And if you press M, you can open like the big map
Oh
And we're looking for the room. That's the exit basically
Okay, we're gonna try not to die. You know, some rooms have puzzles, but I believe are survivable
Okay, I think it's unsafe nifty
Nice, that's two in a row. Wow, we're doing pretty good. Why is this one have a red?
Oh, that's the outside wall that means. Oh, it's a boundary. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay. I wasn't looking at the map
All right, um, which way do you want to go? Should we go this way or that way?
I think we can try this way. Yeah, let's keep hugging the the end. Yeah, I'll throw my boot
I feel like something is gonna happen
No, all right, maybe it's safe
Oh, it's safe. Nice. Wow. Okay
Oh, we can keep what we want. Yeah, let's just keep it going. We're doing pretty well
Easy so they're actually
All right, um, they're not gonna do anything you just gotta wait for them to pass
That's like, uh, this was random. Oh, he's walking through
Oh, yeah
Oh, that's so sad. Can I pick up can I pick up his head?
I don't know. I don't think so. Dang it. I wanted to use his bones in his body
I'm trying to I can't remember. Does that mean the room is dangerous or does that still mean it's safe? I'm gonna try with my boot
Wait, I think that's I think it's good now
I think if that I think they can only be like one event per room. Cool. Yeah, so
Yeah, I feel like that was the free free room. Just don't I think if you run into them, you might take fire damage
I lost this one
Hmm boot
Oh, nope. Nope. That's it
Goodbye shoe. That's the one. Oh, that's the that's the electric one. All right. Now we know not that late
At least we have four tries between us. Yeah
Okay, this one shows us green which I think means it's safe, but I'll test it
It's not safe
I remember nothing
Oh, no, we're like kind of trapped in a corner. Should we go back to this room then?
Yeah, we might have to oh wait this one
Oh wait, this one is yellow like orange. Would you think means to can technically pass through it?
Oh
Does it set it off once?
I think it's just like it's like a laser that goes across. I think you just dodge it in my bear
All right, do you want to try it or
Hey, where'd you go?
Oh, you went to another room
Yeah, I wanted to see if this one's safer
I don't remember what the colors on the ground are supposed to mean
Let me boot it
Get booted
I think we're good. Hey, it says
Nifty. Okay. We probably don't have to take that. That's more dangerous one. Yeah, this will take the safer route
I don't know. I feel like this one's not
Oh, no, okay boot boots acquired
Okay, I think we're doing pretty good. We're doing pretty good. I'm pretty proud of us. Which way should we go this way?
I'll boot it. Yeah boot
Oh, wait, who is that? Oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, careful careful careful careful. I think
I think I don't like that. He's laughing
I think this is one of the crazy like stuck in here people. So they're just gonna be in the corner like saying words
Hey, buddy
Hey, you doing all right? You can follow us out of there. He doesn't have any shoes
Oh, he's out of shoes. Oh, you can you can come with us
Yeah, you can use our shoes. All right. He's I think he's he's too far gone
He's just vibing. He's just vibing in the corner. Oh, yeah, do you want me to try to go this way?
What does it mean when it's yellow on the ground?
Maybe it's safe. Oh
Yeah, it's safe. Okay
I'm every time I'm scared. It's gonna close behind you and you're just gonna die
And I won't be able to see what happens. I don't remember what the colors on the ground are supposed to be
I haven't played this in so long. Yeah, you can tell me milk or if you're able to because I I used to know
Um, but I don't remember
I hate that I can hear that guy giggling
It's pretty creepy
Oh, no
Yeah, that one's deaf. Okay
What is going on in there?
We just find that exit. I'm out of shoes
I only have one left. I might try to go back and get my other shoe, but
Because it's not it's in the yellow one. I'm just maybe I can you want to try I run back
Yeah, I want to try to get my shoe back because it wasn't destroyed. It's just yeah, I feel like you can
Yeah, get that back. Yeah, if I set up the laser and then uh, we just run back in
Yeah, I can run back out once it's uh
I just have to be really fast. Oh wait. No, it's this way. Oh, I almost went into danger. Oh, yeah, sorry
Almost killed myself in minecraft
So I'm gonna throw out one shoe and then I'm gonna go get both of them because then I wish I could still be in there
Oh, yeah, I think it's I think it's activated now
Okay, so maybe if yellow means you can go back in
Wait, where's your other shoe?
Oh, the color tells you how many adjacent rooms have lethal traps. Oh, so it is like mine sleeper. Okay
Uh, if the tile is blue, none of the four connecting rooms have traps green equals one
Yellow is two purples three red is four. Oh
Yeah, it's like mine sleeper. Okay. So the next two rooms probably I definitely have traps then
Uh, this one the floor is green which means one of the rooms have traps. Oh
Oh, okay
So it it's it's one of these two
Have traps
But we kind of already have a safe path back, but I haven't noticed my shoe actually got destroyed. So I can't get it back
Dang it. I thought maybe it would be okay
Because the shoes are left when they exploded
That's true
Oh, okay, I keep going the wrong way. I know it's I'm trying to stare at the map
I keep also thinking I'm you
Oh poor guy, okay, so we know in front of us is deadly
Um, I can try this one
All right shoe it girl. Okay. You don't have any shoe
This room's yellow, which means only two are dangerous
Oh my god
Okay, we made it. We made it. I think that means it's safe now though because I think that's a one-time trap
I don't want to go find out
Yeah, I think the orange is a one-time trap
Oh, I'm glad we got back out though. I know at least it gives you a time. What is this?
Oh, blue means all the doors is safe. I think right
Let me check get blue none of the okay blue means that all all of the rooms next to this one are safe then
So we can check both sides
How do you yeah, how do you tell if and which is the exit?
I don't remember
I think
Um, okay, this is not the exit
All right, I gotta hear him. I can hear him laughing again. I know he's just like in the corner
I love this one
Um, I don't think this is the exit either
Yeah, okay
Yeah, we found we found most of this safe
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm just I hate that the tight the cool down kills me
Yeah, the door is the doors are a pain in the butt. All right
All right, so which which means haven't we checked we've got like
Look at the map
There's the one in the center
Hmm, we could go straight through the center maybe
Yeah, let's do that. It's a good idea
We should be looking for blue rooms
Wait, if this is blue that means this room's also safe
Oh
And this is yeah, this is blue and all the ones around it is safe. Okay
Nice. Okay. We're making some really good progress
We got the sleuths in the chat helping
If I could open the damn door
Should we go should we go this way or should we go down?
Um, let me see what room uh adjacent to this one has
Oh wait, this one's this one's blue as well
Okay
Okay, so this is pretty much all safe rooms. Hmm
Should be good to go this one's green
this one
Follow the blue this room is oh yellow. That's dangerous. We should go green
Green only has one danger room
I'm just letting blue a guide me
like a
Like a silly child
If I run in and die, then you get some oh you still have a shoe
That's true. Okay. This is both green. I'm gonna throw my boot
Yeet
What is that? Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, it's a don't open that again
What that's um, that's a chainsaw guy
That sounds like a terminator
He's yeah, I don't can you leave that room?
Can we I don't remember?
I'm kind of I'm tempted to know
Is he still there?
Hello, oh your shoes there. Oh, he's gone. Oh, nice. I can get my shoe back. Oh sick
All right
This one
Oh, oh, oh my god, he scared the crap out of me
Why are you in safe? Why are you throwing it back homey? What the heck is happening?
How have we not found the exit yet?
Oh
I'm trying
Oh my god, goodbye. Oh no. Oh no. I forgot you can sprint
I fought because the guy wasn't it was safe
So did I how did the guy not die in there?
Maybe you have to go closer to set it off. That was we were doing so well
Oh, no, that's right. We can we can keep trying. All right
Oh
sad
He's super
No, I think uh
Maybe
They this like maybe it's not until I go in the middle for the fan alone. I don't remember
Maybe and then it just gets activated
We always going to use the shoes
shoe
Okay, so this room is green which means one room has a chat. That's yellow
Blue room
But a green room is okay if we can't find a blue one. Oh, this one's blue. Let me test it
There's a dude in this room running around that this one's uh, this one's deaf
I found the trap we can go this one
Oh, we remember we don't know even if a guy's in there
Because the floor is green that can only be one trap. Oh, and that's the trap. You're right. So yeah, that should be it
I think that counts temporary traps as well
I hate this. Oh, no, that only leads to lethal traps all
Wait, is lethal traps all around us?
Um, yeah, why do you sound like a duck? Oh, I want this one. Hold on. It says blue
Never mind
That's too bad
You're playing tag with him
Sorry, the room's getting to me. Yeah, I don't blame you at all
Oh
Was not paying attention that's the flame thriller of is that one
Orange or you've got a red one
Oh
Let's see if it does it again
I think we're good. Let me test it as I walk in
Oh
Where'd my book go? Wait, did I oh no, I've I lost one already. Yeah, we both lost one to like the same type of trap
Okay, uh
Let me see
I wish like I would stop laughing
Okay, this one's green, but it's also a corner room. Let me try the other one first
On the end
Okay
So there's only one way to go
Wait, if the floor is green
You said it's one trap, right?
Yeah, and there's only one direction we can go. So I think that means this one's a trap. That makes sense. Yeah, that's not
Yeah, we mind sleeper mind sleeper
Big brain gotta gotta be careful
It'd be cool if we can mark them as dead. He's that yeah, that would be nice
If you can get in my way, so this should be safe then
Let's trap light to me. No, look it
Okay, orange
That one's death and there should be
Okay, so yellow
Yellow means there's two. Wait, so I think both of these ways are yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. Oh, you'll have to come back
He's so he's so creepy. He really is I wish he would stop
Oh
His mouth isn't even like moving or anything
No, he has the most normal face
All right, oh at least we can jump I didn't know that jump actually no, I jumped multiple times. Um, okay, so
map
We could head towards the top left corner. This one's green, which means I think it's running out
One which is that way so we can go up or down
Long go up. Yeah. Yeah
That's something
Wait, I'm going the wrong way
Where is it? Where is it? There it is
We're all okay turned around
All right, this one it should be safe
I don't even I didn't even throw it
I think we're good. I I tested it with my body
I said
All right, yellow is not great means one direction is definitely dangerous. Uh, do you want to boot it boot?
I think we're good. Oh wait that quick kick wait. No, it's not it's not good over the door over the door over the door
Oh, wait, I think this one you can walk through you just can't get hit by the laser
Oh, so if necessary, we could make it through it. All right, but let me check this one just in case this one's worse
Um, but
Oh, wait, I think this one's good. I think this one's good
Yeah, yeah safety. Okay. We'll we'll take this safe route
What this one? Um, what color was the room that we set that drop off in?
Oh, what does pink mean?
Is pink the exit
Purple means that there's every three adjacent traps, which means like every every trap
Every every yeah, every single exit on that room is a trap
Really? Oh, it's purple purple means. Oh, yeah
Red means there's four so that's even worse
Okay, maybe this way this one's green
Oh, oh wait, this is got a guy. It's got a guy
Oh, but it's a trap guy. I'm about to kill that guy. I'm so sorry guy
I kind of want to watch him die. Yeah
Open the door
Oh, I wish you could have grabbed you might be able to grab your shoe
Well, I think I've just got slime
All right, that's acid, which I think we can't walk on
That's maybe who knows we could try it
Oh, we can definitely
Oh my god, you could definitely grab your shoe
Grab it
Over the timing
I'm gonna run it and grab it as soon as it's on
Go
No, are you good
Oh my god, are you gonna die?
Am I gonna watch you?
Oh, I could take your shoe
Oh, you know, at least you got two shoes now. I can you can go on without me. All right, let's see
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm just gonna speed run through these
Yeah
Wait, isn't this the bad room wait, that's the bat means that you can't go through any of those don't never mind
Well, actually, let's see. Let's see you can you can go right
Um, because remember the one with the spinning laser like the electricity one
If you go on to your right over here, uh, the one that we have marked is orange. Yeah
This one this one you can go through you just can't get hit by the lasers. All right. Let's try it. You should be fine. Yeah
Let's not get hit by the palpitate machine
I'm gonna go over here. Oh, and it's blue. So all the rooms are safe. Oh, okay
Yippee
Wait, oh
That doesn't mean the room is dangerous. That's just the door is dangerous
Speed run speed run
Oh, we're going on the danger door. Oh, I was trying to run through it. It's an ice machine
Did I just get squirted to death? What's happening? You did
I was pretty bad. Well, it was a good attempt. That was not bad.
We're learning. We're learning. One of these times we're going to win
I believe in us
I'm gonna use some beef jerky for good luck
Oh, did they have breakfast already? You said you had a pop part. Yeah, but now I'm having a beef jerky
I need I need the protein, you know
This is a classic balanced american breakfast. I've heard. Mm-hmm. Yep
A strawberry pop tart
All I need is a gun at my hip
Okay, this room is blue. So if it's safe, that'll be nice. I'll boot it. Oh
Oh, I think it's safe
Yay, okay. Should I go down or should we do the edge?
But you should still check doors because they can still be dangerous
Okay, I think this one's good
Now they throw a shoe at you
Okay, green means the one is dangerous
She keeps telling me which ones are dangerous and which one aren't and I keep forgetting
meaning the colors
Yeah, this doesn't necessarily mean the room is dangerous. It's just the door is trapped
I think that'll only go off once though. I think I don't yeah, I think the fire ones only went off once. Let's try it. Yeah
Gonna boot it
Oh
Oh, I guess it's gonna save then
Okay trap doors uh can still be entered. This is yellow though. Does that mean three?
Oh
I read it yellow is two
Okay
So half the rooms are dangerous which is we've already got the one we came from is safe
So we just have to find the other one
Yeah
Oh, I heard something
Who did I oh oh ice room
Wait, this one this one might be possible to pass through if we need to
Let me grab my shoe. Yeah, I was gonna say you can grab your shoe. Okay, so this one will drop ice
Uh, what's this one?
Let's see if this one's worth
eat
Perfect nice we're golden unless something falls from the ceiling like it usually does when I walk in
Um, let me try this one. This one's only got one danger
Oh
Lucky get shabu did
Nice
Wait, this is a good good path so far. Yeah, good path. I'm gonna go this way
Yeet
Yeah
Never mind. Not so good. All right. That's okay
That's the only trap then because it's green. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
This room should be safe then. Oh, we're kind of going back in a circle. Oh, yeah, let's go wait. Where is it?
Where is it down?
We can go we can go. Yeah, we can backtrack
Backtrack a little bit here
And then go down
Oh
It's down safe wait, I think that is safe because they're in this green. That's oh wait, is it is there a guy in there?
Oh, yeah, there's a guy just a dude doing dude stuff
Waiting for a fan to open in the center
Uh, this one's yellow which they said means two and I think that's this way and that way. I think those buffers
Oh, yeah, two ways so
You might want to test it. So just in case
What
Yeah
Checking shoes taken names or this one green means one. So one direction. Please let it not be this direction. Oh, I can't throw
Oh, oh, we could go this way ice. There's ice this one
Once this is gone, uh, I'll boot it
So open up. Where's the door stay open longer? I know the time the cooldown is quite
Oh, well, I will boot it. Never mind
This is not a good area
Oh
Oh my god, explosion just gets me every time
But then aren't we backed into a corner?
This is a dead end. Yeah
She's like it's safe
We still have I have both boots and you have oh, yeah, I have no boots. I am barefoot. I'm living my life
What is this one? This one is orange
I'm gonna boot it
Oh, I think this trap might have been one time. I'm gonna. Yeah, was it the ice one. I can't remember. Yeah, I think it was once
Okay, throw myself in. Oh wait, and the the down this way is red. So that means this way safe
Oh, that's purple. Oh rip
I mean purple is not impossible
What what it is, isn't it?
Wait come on
Purple means three is dangerous, but we were already in an orange one which counts
Hmm. So I think one of the directions might be okay. We can test
Do you want to waste your shoes though?
I've got two of them. We might be close to the exit. Let me test this one
Nope
Okay, that's good. Uh
Wait, you're running in and out
I think that I think that was actually fine. I think you're good
Nifty. Oh, oh, yay. I found it
I can't open the door for you. It's okay. All right, and this is green
Uh, which means one one of the directions is bad. Let's see which direction
Uh, I mean, I've got one boot left. Wait, this one's this one's yellow, which means, um
Which means both of the directions off of it are also bad. So I have to go this way
Oh
Oh, what's that? What is that? Wait, I think that's the exit. Oh, what?
Ah
You know what I'm ready. Do we get extra shoes? Can I get shoes on my hands?
I
Think we can try medium. That was easy. Yeah, it was too easy for us
I couldn't figure out what the exit looked like because I didn't remember. No, we know
No, wait every start actually let me um
Take the time return the lobby
Winner winner chicken shabiner
Standard unity asset dance, yeah
I think all the models are also unity assets
Yeah, something this this is very all very familiar somehow
I
I'll set the difficulty to medium this time. Do you don't make the map bigger?
Sure if you want
We can do a medium and eight by eight that way it'll take a little longer
But I think making the map bigger might mean we have more options too, right?
I hope so
We won't get as many dead ends. Let me turn seven by seven. We'll move up slowly
By the way, you can do up to 13 by 13. Oh my god
That would take so long
Okay, also music is an option to there's an option to turn off the mini map
Oh, no, remember
That's terrible. I would actually die me too. You're an old man
Like you're a woman this time. You be finally what I've always wanted
Um, you gotta pull me tail and red lipstick. Oh me for I wish I could see it my reflection
I didn't realize that you opened that and it scared me
Double shooting it up
Um, should we go are we gonna like hug the corners hug the edges?
Uh, I think one of the directions is bad
Hopefully it's not this direction. Let's go
Oh
Through it at you
I don't know what that is. Wait, I think I think this one might be okay. Oh
We just have to wait for him to finish killing everything in the room first
I kind of want to open the door to see what happens though
I don't mean to I don't think you can leave their room, right?
Oh, you killed my shoe
Wait, he's got shoes on. Oh my gosh got stuck
Can we kill him for his shoes?
Okay, I think he did spawn okay
That's not fair he kills my shoe
Okay, let me this room is blue so we can just walk straight through it nice or we can go this way
Yeah, I want to go down check this room. What color is that one yellow?
This one's green. This one's green. That's good
Because the room we just went in those orange this one's safe in every direction then
Oh, I can try this way this room is also green
Oh, I mean that doesn't mean the rooms. That's like a door trap. I think he's kind of why does he walk it is slow though?
Oh
Nice subtle explosion. Are you telling me I can't pick up his bones. Are you telling me?
Because if we could use his head as a trap for yeah, like come on
I'm gonna go this one
I wonder if I can get more in the middle, maybe
Am I gonna eat a real lunch? No, this one's blue
This looks nice if it was safe. Hey, I think yeah, we're good
Okay, and all directions are also good
Attraction maybe that bigger means some more
No, it's not safe
It's not safe
It was uh, there were icicles that dropped from the middle
Yeah, I could I could see that now
But I mean it means the edges were safe so we know that for the future. Oh god. I'm never stepping in the center of the room again
Yeah, we'll stick to the outer edges. Oh, that one's yellow. It's okay. I'll I'll try to
Try to find the exit quickly. Oh, that was purple. Nope
Uh, okay, what's this one?
Please give me something good green. I can work with green boot
boot
Well, I think it's safe. Please be safe. Please be safe. Please be safe
Stone step in the center
It's it's give us give us the tick
Okay, cool
Okay, um, and if the room we came from was orange, I think I think every direction is safe
Then I'll still be careful. I'm gonna boot everything
There she goes
I'm just gonna start like gaming commenting over your um
Hmm your gameplay hold on me
I have nothing to say about that one folks a man just ran in almost kamikaze'd her absolutely terrifying
She's moving on to the next room
MLG she be cast
For was deciding where to go next. She's eyeing a door. She's opening it ready to throw her shoe
The door is opening slowly
yeet
beautiful
Now this one's safe
I'm making good progress somehow. Yeah, she really is but pure chance. I'm picking the safe room. Oh, jeez. It's good
Okay, that's gonna run out. I don't trust it
What are you what are you saying, buddy?
Fua has met a new teammate. He is currently running in a circle
Very intense stuff amazing
Uh form in his run
Oh, this would be awesome. Let me try it if you could beat them into a room
That'd be great. Throw some throw some crumbs on the ground
You want some food there, buddy
Yeah, I think we have this one safe too. How how is every room? I'm guessing safe
I'm just bad luck. It seems
With she be dead. She is able to move forward looking for the safe room
I'm checking for a blue room. Okay, the both green. Oh, it's another guy
Sorry, maybe if you just like run in real fast. Okay. Yeah. Oh
Oh
My boat
Not the boot
It's new friend clucking. Yes
She means no to have bad luck. Yes
Oh
I don't know how I'm getting so so lucky
Oh, do you see that jump? Dang. He's got moves
I can't do that. Right, buddy. He's he's skipping
I really wanted I really want to see the person in the booth that recorded this
Oh, what is that a black hole? Oh, okay. That was very dangerous actually
I don't know if the black hole is temporary
But I think that was the only capsule
boot
Oh, there you go find the exit for both of us. Oh, well, it is yellow
So I think you should you are good if you were to go through that room again
And this one's blue. So I think this is safe, right?
You had a boot and you didn't use it just waiting for you just to like combust
I mean the ground was blue. So I don't think there can be traps, right? That's a good point. Oh, it's another guy
There's so many though. Okay last boot
Oh, we're golden. Okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah, just avoid the center just in case
Well, this is blue blue room. Oh, no
Oh my god
Goodbye boot. I'll miss you. Oh, you did the most boot
All right. Good luck. Let's go green and that was this one's safe, right?
Yeah, I think you're good. Okay in this room
Um, yellow dangerous. So this one should also be safe. Oh god. I don't want to go in a yellow room
Oh
I'm gonna backtrack for a moment. Go for it
All right, let me check this one. This one's green. Oh, no, that means this way's also it could be a yellow room though
So
All right, what was this one?
Wait, this one's blue. Okay. Okay. This one's both directions are safe.
Not careful of the doors though still all right. I don't want to get lasered like I did
um, what's this one
Trying to find the exits. I want like run in run out
Oh my god, you have the most ultimate luck
Yeah, somehow
She's zoom in everybody. This is the medium difficulty
I don't have any boots to find the danger room
Okay, you got blue and green
It was a good one folks in the end who would get slimed and tends to acid bits
Yeah, it was pretty good
In the arms of the angel
Wait, we're getting tired again. This one's much harder
Oh, you I don't know you made that look pretty easy. I was very impressed with your skill
I was just running all what?
What how don't we start in the purple room? What?
Wait every single direction is dangerous then
Huh, how do we well, maybe it's um
Maybe it's like there's a trap room
Yeah
All right god speed
Let's go. Let's try this. There's a dude in this one boot
Uh, well, this one's the sun. Um, so I think this one this one has the ice. Okay. I think it's this one. Yeah. Yeah
I think this is good. Yeah, this one's fine
What try to get my boot back this one may get my boot too
Oh, this guy's still alive too. Can I live through that? Oh, no, I think it ate my boot
Never mind
Still going off
All right, nice
This way. Yeah, this one's blue. So
Oh yellow that means all directions are safe
All right, do you want to go yellow is not great
Let's try this way. I think I think yellow means that one of the direction has to be dangerous. Okay. Let's try it
It's that one
Oh, this one we can go in then
Oh my gosh, we are winners gamers get all to make gamers
Easy
speed running half dead
I
Just not good. I wish I could like orange justice
Dancers and stuff we can do in game. Yeah any emotes do you have any like an emote wheel?
uh jump throw
Team chat
Nah mark dangerous rooms. Oh, we can mark dangerous room. Wait, where's the oh, it's oh
Oh
Oh, you can put an exclamation mark on the mini map. Oh, okay. Oh, all right
We don't have a dance though, but we did start in the blue room. Which is safe. That's nice. That's nifty
So I can go in any of the rooms but still be careful the doors. They can still be deadly
Okay
There's one of these directions blue
That would be great
Oh
Careful the middle still though. Yeah, I'm still I'm not trust in no middle
Blue blue blue green green with this one
I believe we found it that yellow. I know that was really impressive. So we go to the green one. Oh, yeah, we can go green
Oh bad. It's not so bad
That's so slow
Oh
Maybe uh, oh that one's yellow. That's
What's this one?
This one is green is what I put it
Oh, what does that one do?
Oh, it's an exploding guy. He's gonna he's gonna explode. Okay, then make sure we can still walk through there
Yeah, maybe you're hopefully your shoe is still there. Oh sweet
Nice free shoes
Okay, let's let's test it first then we can get a free boot. That's lucky. Yeah, let's I'm gonna mark it on the map
Okay, careful the store is laser
I'm trying to
Mark it. Oh, I hear someone in here
Hi buddy, how you doing kiddo?
I don't think he's okay. He's doing like hopscotch or something. I don't know
Okay, I put a red exclamation point on this room under the yellow so it looks like we should we know where the boot is
Excuse me, sir
Oh
Hopefully this is a good room. Hopefully this is a good room. It's not a good room. It's not a good room
Oh, I totally wasn't pretty good. I thought we didn't have any rooms around us. I'm so silly
Oh, why am I like this? Wait, actually
Oh, wait, no, this won't kill me. Oh, I thought that it would kill me
Rest in peace. All right, let's see how long I can go
Just running into random rooms. Oh nice. Enjoy the purple room
So there's one one way is safe, right?
I was gonna find it. Yeah, it's that one. No, it's not. It's that one
It's this one. This one's safe. It's it feels good to me. It's this one pretty sure
Yeah, see why is this room also purple? No
Wait, what was that? I don't even know
Uh, oh, I think you don't even know what happened. Well, you can grab the shoe because your shoes are over there
True. I got an extra boot
Let's go
With the foo, I carry this one
Did we test this one? I don't know
Oh wait, that room's green. So I think it's good. Okay, I'll start a speed run
Maybe this one feeling good about it. It's yellow. Oh, what's this one?
Oh
Pick the safer of the yellows
Okay, so one of these sections is safe
Another yellow. What are you? Let's get a blue
Another yellow. Okay
boot
Not that one
This one should be safe winner winner
Oh, okay. What is this one? Wait, I think it's almost deadly. Oh, hello
Hey buddy, you can explode he's taking a sweet time
He's cool guys don't look at explosions
Uh, what about where you came from? I kind of want to like give that guy a hug
and see if
I forgot I forget when you hear that stone noise like a stone being moved. There's icicles in there. That was a double trap
What the hell ouch
I forgot it. We're not supposed to go in the middle. Yeah. Oh my gosh
Hey, look at him this time
I'm I'm feeling good
I'm feeling good. We're gonna we you know after that one speed run we just did of course we're gonna have one
That doesn't go so smoothly. That's true. We can
We used all of our power. Oh blue with this one. Oh, no
But it means that we can wait if that one's blue. I mean, oh
Is it gonna if it's blue that means that all their rooms? How do you mark them as safe?
Um, do you see that thing? Oh
Oh, I can mark them as blue. Okay. Yeah, it means those two rooms around it are safe
So if we can get to them we can go through them
So this room should be safe, but avoid the middle still. What type is happening? I just froze. Oh, I have to unclick. Oh
Um, if I did this correctly this room should also be safe
I wish that it would show up for me as well
Yeah, I think the exclamation point is local. Yeah
I marked it anyways
It's pretty smart though
It would be nice if this one was safe
It should be yeah, because it was it's not won't step in the middle and this one is safe
Oh careful doesn't mean it can't have guns
What is that? That's not the fire like before
Okay, it's uh
Sun laser a sun laser
At least the power of the sun
The power of the sun in the palm of this one is yellow, but since this room is a trap
Uh, wait, which is yellow too. Oh wait yellow means both
Oh, okay, so never mind. We can still we can still see if it's a deadly trap. We can boot it
Yep
No
Are you out of boots?
Oh, am I? Yeah. I'm out. I'm out of boots already out of boots. Oh, no
I got too boot-happy
You got that booty
We're good. We're good. Um
Wait, is this one's yellow and both the directions would better save than I think
Oh, you ran in I thought you were still in there. It's like wait, why are you I lived I lived
Um, I think we would have to backtrack a little bit
Oh, yeah, because I think this is yellow then it's got two death and two of the we've already found the safe ones
This one's also yellow, which means this one should be death
Like that it's purple. No, I don't have one boot
Okay, that means that if that one is purple, should we backtrack some more and go up here?
Oh, it's purple then all of these could be deadly. Okay
I was marking them. Wait, this one should be deadly then though, right? Because it's pink on the other side
But yeah, it's probably something
Oh, wait, this one's not bad. We can just wait right for these spawn
Don't blow up my shoe. Oh, yeah, we can get your shoes too. You can get a free shoe. Yay
Nice, that's lucky actually
sick
Free boot get that boot
All right, I'm not bootless anymore
Oh, hi, what color is it yellow?
Uh, it was the one down here that's dangerous, right?
Did you mark it on your right? I remember I'm like the different one. Okay
So this one could be old purple though, so it's yeah, I think that was I'm just gonna
Ignore that one
Yeah, oh, this is all so purple
Maybe this one, please one is green green. That's not bad. Yeah, try this one
What is it doing? Oh, it's like lit up guy that one's not
Please don't that's the chainsaw, man. Please don't kill my shoe
Hopefully not
Did you kill my shoe? We can uh
Can I grab it? I can go through this room. Oh, I grabbed it. Oh sweet. Nice
Okay, that's not bad. We're we're doing good making progress
I think all the directions should be safe because the room we came from counts as long as I'll check
This one's a yellow. Oh, I can't throw
And I think I think this corner should be safe
Okay, over here is safe, but it's a corner, but I can check if it's uh
I can check if it's the ending. No, it's not. Okay
Okay, well, I marked it with that stitch
Hey, I was just marking that corner sick
Well, we'll color this one. Oh, okay one direction bad one direction is good
Please don't oh, I knew it was going to be pink
She's telling about you
He took a shit. Oh no, uh-oh
Wait, that means this one's safe, but it is um
It is it is purple
So wait, wait a minute. I do know I do know that this way is dangerous and I do know that this way is dangerous
Okay, so it's this one
Wait, no, because then you said it was this is the only one then because you said it's all of them except for one
Which means it could be livable you can risk it risk it for the biscuit. Hopefully it's a door trap
Yeah, why is the one purple too? Oh, man
Uh, what's this one? What's this one?
Maybe this one's not that bad
Oh, wait
Yeah, we already we already said that was that was we've already went in here. Oh, there's a guy that blew up
Can we go this way?
Oh my god, we're surrounded by purple
But let me look at the map. Which direction can we go? Uh, we're like we need to go to well, we could backtrack
I think we have to yeah, yeah and go all the way back near that where that yellow is
Hmm
I don't remember what that yellow one was. Yeah, do I maybe it was a guy that also I think maybe it was a chainsaw, dude
Let's see
This one is oh, it's the blade
We can run through it. You just have to be really fast. Yeah, which one do you want to go to?
So any direction safe. Um, do you want to let's try rushing left? Okay
All right, three two one run
Let's pull me
Oh, of course it's a purple purple
Well, I mean, we've already know that two of them are traps so we could check one of the other directions
I will boot this door just in case
Teleport guy. Oh, that's not bad. That's not bad. That's it. Oh, okay
Is he gonna destroy your shoe?
Yeah, that's not bad
Okay, that's that's you might be able to grab it
Oh, is he done? Oh, that was quick. Yeah, he was fast. I was a fast guy
All right, we might still have a chance
Um, this room's yellow
means two directions are dangerous
Um
I want to beat a room. I'm scared. It's gonna have the laser
Laser walls, if you're yeah, the laser walls of the trap. I'm gonna bait it
Oh
I'll boot it just in case. Oh, oh
Okay, but back up the this one is okay once it's already gone off, but nice. I might lose my boots. No, not the boot
Wait, what do you mean woman on the stream, you know, I'm a woman, right?
You're a woman
I count you come on. What do you mean? What?
Hey
I am an adult woman
She just happens to have cat ears. Okay. She's just a little bit different
Okay, this one's safe now, but I did lose my boot
Okay, we'll have to bait stuff actually. No, I got the dogs out. Oh, they bark in
Oh
I think both. What does the red mean that that means every directions. Okay. We're not gonna go that way
That's what what is this guy doing in there?
Let's let you know. It's okay. Purple. They're both purple on either side. Um
Oh that should be backtrack
I
Think we probably should
Damn, this one's hard. Uh, we can try it
Um, what should we go down? This one was yellow. Yeah, we could try one of the other rooms
I'll do it. What's this? Yep. Yeah
No, oh no, goodbye
I wish if I hugged the edge. I feel like if I hugged the edge, I shouldn't die
That's why they put the blue there
Okay, well, um, I know we're both the traps but that one's a dead end
Rip
Okay, um
I will I will purchase
I'm so proud of this game. I thought fool was a 43 year old man from michigan
Did you hear that god damn
I already told you I'm a 73 year old man. Not 43. Oh my god. I'm a 56 year old woman. He stayed
My time I got you pooped over there. Why are there gray clouds? Wait, I think this is gonna save us. Oh, I was wrong
I've made a grave error. Why is it always the acid? Why is it always the acid with me?
I know you always
You always get Nickelodeon slined
um, man
37 for six years now
Well, it was a good run. It was indeed
This is so much. I forgot how actually hard this game is. I know I can't get super hard and I'm terrible at puzzles
so
I'm trying to remember stuff, but then I'm like, yeah, this one's safe. Then I ran in and died
Wait, this one's yellow and there's only two directions we can go. They're both
They're both
Why do they do this to us? I'll shoot this one
Oh
I almost walked into that
I think it's your one. I think I'm gonna take this one. I almost backed up into that
Don't go in the middle. All right
I don't know what kind of death it is though
Oh, wait. No, no, no get out. Oh, okay. Get back out. Get back out. We gotta wait for him to despawn
Did you just like come to daddy
Wait, did he really? Oh, he's not like it went up. I thought come to daddy
Still doing stuff. Oh, okay. We good green
Yeah, this one's good. It should be safe in both directions
Let me check what color this one is. This one is
Yellow. Okay. They're both yellow. Yeah. Oh, I didn't throw that properly. I'll try. I'll test it. Oh, no
Why did you run it?
I thought it was safe
No
I thought it was safe for you. I missed I missed judge you did it by mistake
I missed the shoe throw
No
Oh, there's a dude in here. I'm just gonna speed run. No
Okay, we'll see if we can find it this time. I don't think we've passed with only one of us alive yet. No, actually, no. Yeah, you're right
Um
You never know might be my moment a time to redeem myself
Oh, that was oh
well
Imagine I went in that one and I would have been slimed
Wish I could kill you and use your body
Yellow and yellow
Yeah, maybe that one's all right. Okay. Okay. We're we're we're making progress. I think out of this
Hopefully this one's yellow, which means I think this could be a danger. Yeah, you're right. Okay
Um, but it could be an orange in here. So it might be livable if necessary. Yeah. Yeah. Well, let's try this one
Sounds like someone's peeing in there. I think this one should also be livable. I mean it it might be
It should be a subtle tap. What is that? What is that?
It's the oh, that was that was oh, that's the cross laser. Okay. Okay. You did that one before
It sounds like a goose
All right, what about this? Um, this one's yellow, which means too
You got this
I got time. I got time. Oh my god another pink. Oh, oh god. Okay. Um, well you found one of them
Please take a gamble
You can get the one in front of you or the one behind you
Oh picked the one in front of you
You picked correctly. You picked incorrectly. Wait. No, that's only the middle. Actually, that's fine. Okay. We're good
We're good. That's not that bad. Yeah. Okay. What if I go
Oh
Wait, isn't this not the right direction though? Because it's yellow
uh
Yeah, yeah
Come on you can backtrack
Oh, I'm going the wrong way
I keep messing up my sense of direction
Or if I go in the center, wait, no, that's not where I wanted to go
Actually, let's go in here. Wait. No, I can't. I'm trapped in the center
Let's hope. Do I have a shoe? Do I have no shoes?
Okay
Okay, one of these doors is safe. Good luck
Let's test my luck. I'm putting it all in luck. Let's say that's green. That's bad
I hear water
Yeah, I think that's the acid still going
Oh, that was my dead body. Okay, let's swimming
Let's try this. Let's try. Let's try it. We'll beat. We'll beat. We'll beat. Did that count?
Oh, oh, okay
Wait, you picked it. Oh my god. Oh my god
We're baiting
Master baiting. I mean wait
Um anyways
This actually might be fine
I mean the room is green so only one direction is dangerous. Okay
Okay
Okay, all right. Not bad. Okay. Once again only one of these is dangerous
Let's see if this is the one
Yo
What's happening here? Wait, she's doing it
Which way should I go?
Blue I feel like this is a trap
Iced again
I don't look at the door
Yeah, there's so many things to remember. Oh, I never look at the door
No
How could this happen to me? CB2 ice three
I
Think I've been slimed as much as you've been iced. Yeah, so my enemy is ice yours is slime. Mm-hmm
All right, Elsa versus slime girl. Ooh
Actually, I remember I remember uh
Uh, no, no, no, no. I got him. Why am I so bad with names?
He just ran around me in the circle. You were thinking honey. Yes, honey
You did a character design for the next round and she said no slime girl. Yeah, she hates slime girls. Oh
I was gonna explode
scared
Oh, yeah, no, she's she's she's anti slime girl
I don't think they can be cute. Oh, it's it's oh, yeah, they're awesome
And I like the like what they can like kind of shape shift and stuff
Hmm, um, but in terms of like rigging and making art outside, there's only like I only know like two slime v-tubers
So it's like pretty difficult to get that effect
What my like oh my god. Oh, we have another one my stream mascot thing is one small slimes
Oh, so we got two shoes. Hold on
Okay, I'm gonna mark it. Oh, what do you want?
Is it this one?
Uh, what color is this room?
I'll test it in this room
Oh, I heard something
Oh, that's the eyes
Or like the center when it makes that noise it does that
It it was something in the middle, but I don't know what that was. Yeah, I don't know. It's like some
Anti matter junk
Well, it's gone out sweet
Wait, maybe we should go straight instead
I think all directions should be good. Nope, except that one. Oh, that's purple
I don't like the purple rooms. Oh, no
This one was green, right? Yeah, okay. Yeah
Oh, wait, we just I got an achievement. You did
Yeah, I think this is gonna play before it says I've discovered 300 rooms. Jesus christ
That's right when I played 10 years ago. I think I was playing this alone
Oh
Wait, oh, we have to go in his room. Go in there. I'm going there. I
I forget that I can run. Yeah, that's I forgot that that could be a thing that he just spawns in
Yeah, and then he takes your room. So you just have no choice but to move forward. Oh dang. That's intense
Oh, oh, I got a danger danger guy. Oh, what the heck? Um, I'll boot behind him though
I
I need eight years to
I didn't think that was something that could happen
That's so funny. I'll go back and get the other boot in a minute. Let me boot this reverse. Okay
Wait, something in the middle. Careful in the middle
What is that?
All right dark matter dark matter moment. I don't actually know what dark matter is
Something about space. I think did you get the boots? Oh, you did
Uh, I've got one. There's another one. Oh, oh, no
Okay, we have to backtrack and I think I'm gonna go back and get that boot. Hey, what's happening in this room?
I hope the chainsaw man's gone
I bet he is
Do you remember which room the boot was in? No. Oh, this is this is the floor is lava. What but I could totally get my boot back
Let me in
Oh, I found it. Okay. I've got my boot. My boot is fine. I'll come back
All right, should we should we go up?
Yeah, we can try to go this way. I think this one's safe, but I'm gonna boot it just in case because uh,
Oh, it is purple though
Are you safe?
Oh, no, but I mean, uh, which one was this the orange one is this this is okay. I think right. Yeah
Um, yeah, I think this is the room that I don't remember actually try it. I think this way should be dangerous
Uh, uh, uh, yeah, this one's guaranteed. Let's backtrack
No, I don't like those directions. They're very dangerous. Wait, wait, look at the boot
You have to pick it up. You have to press yeah
Nifty boots back. Let's go. Perfect
Um, which color is this room?
All right, I'm gonna boot it
I'm feeling good. Okay. We just have to find the safe way
I'll boot it this time
Oh, that's not bad. We can wait. Yeah, we can wait for that one. Goodbye shoe. I could have grabbed my shoe
Maybe we're too late now
No
Dang it. This one's green. Oh laser
I almost got iced
Not the ice
Uh, one of these should be technically safe
Boot uh, well, okay. This way is good. This one
This way is good. Um, I'll meet you over there
So that I can mark this one as well
Nifty look at us
Well, let's try I only have one boot again. Oh, you do why so do I?
Yeah, uh, what's this one?
This one's green. This one's yellow. Let me grab my shoe. We can go that way
Hello, I think both are good
Let's go to the green room
safer
Can I grab it? All right, I did
This one. Oh, no. Oh, no. Um, I made a mistake. I thought this room was safe
I can't miscalculate. I trust my own judgment too much. Oh, but honestly your judgment's like pretty accurate like
80% of the time so I don't blame you for that
Let's try it. Let's try I have one boot to my name. Yep
All right
I can't do
Quick maths blue let's go for it. I don't know. That'd be good if it's blue
Okay, that means all directions are safe then. All right. The exit could be outside of one of these maybe
I'm hoping
Well, I feel like the exit's probably not in the room with the guy probably not
That was suck for it
Otherwise, he's just stupid
Oh
I saw it that time
Not this time. Not this time. Nice try
buddy
Nice try open the freaking door
I'm getting I'm getting spun around
Okay, this one both directions are dangerous. I don't know for two directions
Let me go this way just in case
Yeah, that way it might be but
Oh, it's blue. Oh wait. That's great. That means it's safe completely
You hit the corners
Let's check the corner carefully doors
Oh
Oh the thing it's blue shut the door close the door
Okay
Oh
Well now you guys got up. I just I'm just stuck
It's wait room. Are you little there now? All right
I mean this room. Oh, I mean it's a room that if you want to walk through would have been fine
Um, what was that?
It was ice again. I just walked by it. I didn't even care
I mean they're trying to ice me
They really are they're trying to get me
Let's see. Where should I go? I'm trying to freeze some rabbit fur the window
Oh my gosh, there's literally like a good chunk of the map we haven't gotten to yet. Yeah seven by seven is a lot bigger
We uh, we
We've done like two first one third
Oh, come on, bro. Oh, is he gonna kill him?
He just killed that man. Oh, no
That one's safe, but you're just gonna be carefully going in the right direction. Oh wait. No, no, it's not. No, it's not
Help
Maybe oh my gosh, how did I just am I good you guessed correctly? Wow
I'm maxing out on luck
Oh
You have to go in his room. Why is this keep happening?
They're forcing you into them
Oh my god, I thought he was still behind me. Okay, that's yellow
This room is green, so
Only one is dangerous out of the two that you have available
Or you can backtrack
If you still have a boot you do still have a boot. I do I still have a boot. You're right. I do still have a boot
There's something about this that I think is good
Yeah
lucky
Let's keep moving forward. All right, so um two out of the three that you haven't checked in this room are deadly
And I think you just found the lucky one
Okay
And this one's blue so they should be all safe, but they can still have door traps
Oh, yeah, I should probably stand so close to the door
Okay, yellow again
Can I get like a green yellow again? Oh, they're all yellow
God damn. Um, you probably want to avoid ending up in the corner. I guess yeah, I'll go down
But other rooms are safe so you could label them as safe
Is there a dude in this room? Hello? Hey, are you good?
Oh, I heard something. I think the middle's dangerous. Yeah the middle again. Oh
Oh, goodbye. I hope I didn't slime my shoe
I think it's good
Oh, thank god, excuse me, bro
All right
This one should be safe because the one next to it was blue. I'm just trying to get the green
Oh
We did it. Well, you did most of it at the end
Yeah
I sacrificed myself
Up was only with your sacrifice that I could
Move forward. Thank you
A pleasure
My tomagotchi's still dying
Oh, no, you didn't even take a moment to feed him. I had to clean up his poop a moment in my my one
I need to like google why
It has gray clouds around it. Is it the super depressed? I don't
Well, I don't think my one can do that
Tomagotchi, I know that you had like uh, you have one of the colored ones. Yeah, the uni
Oh, I want to get one of those now. Oh, I have to clean with
The vacuum
There's a vacuum. Yeah, there's a vacuum robot
I had no idea I've I want to I want to get an uni. I want to get the hollow live one as well
I know the hollow live one's already sold out
Yeah, maybe next time I go to japan I could find a second hand one. That's true. You can get the um
You can get the wigs though with the code
Oh, really? Yeah, that's why I have um my tomagotchi dressed up as pekara
I thought you had the hollow live one because you had the wig
No, it comes out in 2025. That'd be sick if I just randomly was I'm hella sponsored stream
It's very very privileged early access. Yep. I'm just you know, I'm just built different whole year advanced
You think I feel like you wouldn't be allowed to take pictures of it actually, you know, yeah, that's that is true
Status, okay. I need to feed you like two more times and then you will hopefully stop being depressed
Have some have have a you know what have some somen noodles
All right
Let's do this. This will probably be my last one
We'll give it a our best go
I can't believe she'd be would sacrifice the cat girl. No
It's sacrifice sacrifice myself. It's okay. That's different. Oh, that's green. I'm gonna shoot it
It's unsafe
You know what? Let's just go to that one. There's a guy. There's a guy. Oh great. There's a guy
Hey, which model are you this time you oh, you're you're the bold guy again. You are an old gray man
Why am I always the old man? Oh, that's like that. Maybe like the second time
I think this one should be dangerous
Because the floor is green and we're in a corner. Oh, that's a good point track actually. Yeah
There's another room that was green every which one it was
So that one
Oh, they say this one's yellow. Okay. It was this one that was green then
Hopefully this one's safe. Yeah. Oh
Good thing we double shoot it to make sure
Yeah
Careful the middle still yeah, because it seems like it's really late. It doesn't check check it out. Oh, no
Oh, I just heard something. Oh my god. What was that? Oh nice try
Well, I see in the middle. They always get ice try even. Yeah, this one should be safe. Yeah
Oh, this one's green so it should be safe in both directions. Uh,
I'll see what color this one is. This one is green. I'll boot it. Is that one good?
Yeah, okay, let's do that one then
Mine was yellow
Okay, look at us. We're like master master gamers at this now
Oh
You can speed run it
Try to trigger the middle. Uh, that's where we go
So one of these is dangerous. Uh
A pink one probably is
Oh
That means that the room we are in
Is the only safe room attached to those so maybe we backtrack. Okay
What color was this one?
All right, so this one is dangerous. However, it could be it could be survivable. So I'm gonna throw something in it
boop
Oh, what are you good toss
What are you? Oh, no, no
Um, I mean it's survivable
But we'd have to run
Directly at the door you want to go through
Oh, okay. Um, do you want to try over here then? I mean, sorry over wait. No. Yeah, we gotta run
It's it's it's one out of three. I don't know. I'm I'm taking the risk
I'm gonna do it
I'm going I'm going to this way
Okay, I'll go I'll go the right one. I'll go the right one
I'm good. It was it's uh, it's it's not the right one. Oh, it wasn't
Nope
Nice
Oh my god
Impressive, which one was that one? I don't I don't have any boots. Love. I got boots. Don't you worry
Oh
Poggers
Professionals we are so gorgeous
Incredible
Wait, what are they what are they doing? I wish I could see past the screen what their little dance was
Like how you have no shoes and I have shoes
Okay, one more one more one more. Yeah, that was really fast. That was fast. We speed run we can we can be all right
All right, let's see. I'll test this
Oh, hello exploding, dude. Thanks for the free boost. I'll take it appreciate it big preach
Oh, I think I might have messed up my boot girl
It kind of you you you took his shoe that was there though
It's like a it's a boot transfer now it's in the now it's in the doorway
Wait, I'll test oh
I
Yeah, this one's green kind of see what happens when I touch him
I just died
I know I die, but how do I die?
but
Oh
Yeah, I'm I'm I'm trained. Oh, that's so smart rooms
Yeah, I think that's actually like kind of like the move for me when you get those
But that's what they intend for it to do. They don't have to waste it. Yeah
This one's also green. Yeah, and then you don't have to backtrack. Oh ice ice. Oh fire
And I said fire
To the cat girl
All right, there's a guy in here i'm gonna boot it
I'm gonna grab the other boot
I'll get in here
He's got crushed in the door
I
Thought Bruce I can with the screen we might have died
Sorry
All right, one of these directions is bad. I'm gonna go this is a blue this one. I found it. It's this one
We cannot we can go through this one. It's safe
But still be careful of the middle. I never trust the middle same
Hey, this one's blue that should be good
Um, do you want to go? I'll check. I'll check. Oh, we got a toxic skill in man
He'd be toxic
It's kind of a cool animation. Well, I'm not gonna lie
Oh
The little explosion kind of gets me every time
All right, this one's blue. Nice. Yeah
Oh, it should be good in either directions
Hmm, you just gotta pick which one we want to go through. Okay, they're both green. I'll just clear the corner
I'll go through this one
Come on
Yeah, you know as i'm sitting here drinking and getting myself so you guys know that shabby also has a code
Oh my gosh, what's your coach?
My coach fool. Your coach fool. My coach shabby. What a coincidence
Oh
I lost my shoe
Sadly, uh, yeah, I can see that I can see the death in there
I'm um
I'm drinking gamer subs right now as we speak. I'm drinking some lean
I am kind of drinking cold pee. Um, yeah
Okay, this one's safe. Um
Um
But the room adjacent to it this way is definitely not safe, but it could be it could be orange
So I kind of want to test it
Huh, what?
Uh, but this room's great. It should be should be deadly. That's weird. Wait, does that mean?
Maybe it's the middle. Maybe it's the middle. It must be the middle
Yeah, I'll I'll run in. I'll run in. I'll look I'll test it with my body here. Have my shoe just in case
I'm almost gonna come in. Oh, look it up
I figured out what it was
Did you get your shoe back? Okay, good. I did. Yeah chainsaw man looks different from what I remember in the end of the day
Okay, okay, cool. Cool. I wish he would leave a shoe. I'll be great
All right, let me test this one. I'm feeling good about this run boot. All right. Well, I figured out which way it was
Uh, other boot
All right, this one should be safe. Is there a guy laughing here? Okay
Uh, this one's green. So it should be that the room came from was was it? Oh purple
Please be something good. Okay. Yellow manageable
Yeah, yellow is tolerable careful of the middle though. Yeah
Oh, we're good. Um
Hoping this one could be orange. That's what we need. We need this blue
Okay, so this room should be a trap, but it should be a safe trap. Okay. Oh great
Did I grab it? No, I thought I grabbed it
Maybe it lived. Maybe it lived. Hopefully it lived either way. You'll get a boot. Oh, I got a free boot, right? Yeah
Oh, that's too bad. That's good
Oh
Please be green or blue. Okay, yellow yellow
Manageable wait, this it should be safe because but the middle can still be dangerous
I'm not safe and marked itself
Okay, this room is yellow. So this is green could have it
All right, uh, thank you misty boot. I know I kind of did
I think it's good. Oh, yeah, I think my room's the deadly one then
I won't bother testing it
You should go you should still go into the purple rooms if you know they're safe in case the exit spawns. Oh, that's a good point
That's true. That's a good point
We didn't know they were safe, but we can check it. Yeah, we can go back and check it back and check. Yeah
We got boots. Yeah boots because that would be funny if wait, which one was it
Be funny if we just like ran past and exit because we were scared of the purple room. Yeah
Oh, it should be this one
All right, let me check watch it be green. It's not the exit. That'd be so funny though. All right
There right though, I would see purple and I'm like nope
I'm not even gonna bother
That's scary. I'm scared of the color purple
Purple guy
I'll test this room in the boot
up
Mine's a bad one
This doesn't help too much. It's a corner. Oh, no
That is a blue corner. Oh, hello. Hello, sir
I would
Gladly give you a hug
What a handsome dapper gentlemen
Oh
And he's gone. Oh, he's looking at me. Hi. I wish I could crouch
Okay, this is green. So I think I think the sleigh should be safe. Yeah, because that one's the red
I'll still oh careful
Ha ha
You thought you could get us with the flamethrower wrong we're ultimate gamers
Okay, this one should be safe, but I'm gonna boot it. Okay
save
Green oh wait, it should be safe again for both directions because yeah, that one I lied it should be one dangerous
Yeah, I'll put this one. I don't have a boot
This one's I think it's on safe
Let's do it
Oh, it's just middle. It's the middle
middle
Slime
Nice try
Uh, I'll check the other room. I thought you're about to walk into the slime. No
I don't want to get slimed again that badly
All right, I'll check this room
Not the exit. Okay
Um, um, um, let me see this room. This is Jason's theory. No, I'll meet you halfway. It's yellow
Oh
That means this should be this should be trapped. Okay
Because uh, it only has two directions, right? Yes
This one's green over here
And this one's green. I'm gonna bait
Oh, I found a purple room. Oh, uh, goodbye cruel worlds. Oh, no, did you die?
Uh, I'm in the process. I'm gonna die from lava
I'm I'm screaming the floor is lava. Although I'm standing on a non lava patch
Uh, turns out this room is safe
No
Okay, you have to carry
I I got this. What color is the room you died in? Uh, I don't recall
Purple. I think it was purple. I think it was yellow
I got this
Okay, okay, okay zooming
Oh, okay, this one's green. Um, but
Okay, that's all I find. I want my boot. I want my boot. Nice. Nice. Nice. Nice. Gamer shats. Yeah
I can walk through here now though
So loud
Okay, let's just be safe now
Um, it's green. Let me see
What about the room that was right past you?
Um
yellow, which means
In a CR corner that the corner over there means that it means that corner is safe. Let me check this one
Green which means the room I'm in is the only dangerous one. Okay. I'm gonna check it. Oh come on. Oh, no
Okay, um, I'm just gonna
I believe in you
Oh, what if this corn is the ending that would be crazy that would be so crazy
Oh, okay. Gotta do some backtracking. I want you to speedrun this though
Yeet. I'm gonna have this door opening closing sounds of my nightmares
Uh, yeah
Okay, green. I gotta see if I can find the movie that this game is kind of based on
Yeah, I don't want to watch it now. I mean this one's purple
So that should be something. Uh, what's this one?
Uh, that means this one should also be a trap. I just don't know which I could get running now eat
Oh, okay
The middle is tolerable. Yeah, it was good
Good old middle trap
I'd really like a new boot
I know we need a guy to come run at you
Yeah, I need someone to explode at me
Okay, these should be safe because it is green
Okay pink
Purple
Yeah, I just wanted to mark it. Okay
Let me see your destruction
Oh, I didn't go in this one. Maybe there was a specific reason why I didn't
Just in case I'll check this one. Sorry. I think that you knew that one was a trap
If I could recall correctly because the other room was like
And I know this one's a trap. I should mark it. I'm gonna mark it. Oh
All right, if I know that one's a trap then this should be safe, right mind sleeper rules
Hopefully the last time I thought the last time I thought this I ran and died. So let's see if I did that again. Oh
Pretty good
Oh, yeah, uh, wait, I want to check what color the room that I was marking is
What what color is this one this one is
Green oh, okay. Um, if that's green and I have two of these exits marked
Then there is a 50 50 chance that that room is dangerous
Are you gonna take the chance?
As long as I just have a wall, you're fine. Oh
I think you're good
She's doing it
Gaming okay, I like those odds. Um this room
I have no idea yeet
Oh, wait a minute
Yeah
Okay, okay, okay
Oh
Blue
I have absolutely no idea
No, I didn't have to have that. I didn't have any boots. Good night. Good night
Only if it didn't have the stupid wall you would have been fine
Oh, man. Yeah, I would have been able to run out of it
That's right. That's pretty good. We actually I look pretty good when I played this. I think I only passed once so wow
So honestly not a bad run not a bad run for for like two hours as well
That's not bad at all. Yeah, so be a good thing to play with like viewers and stuff too
I would just force viewers to go in and kill themselves and minecraft for me, you know
I think you can have up to four people, but I'm sure you can mod it to have more. Oh, yeah, that's true
You can use them as body bags. Yeah, perfect
Well, thanks for hanging out with me Fula. I'm tapping out
Thank you as well. You can eat me. I've been up so early. Oh, it's 10 a.m. That's early for me. Okay guys
It's okay. I wake up in the evening so I can judge
Right next time we can we can sit a little bit later for you, but I appreciate you doing that early for you
Yeah, I wanted to do it early for you. I also found a two. I appreciate it
Yeah, of course I went and I told I told everyone I'm just like she'd be so nice
I was like you probably have to you know accommodate people that are in different time zones
So let me try to accommodate your time zone and you're like every other collab I have this
I've had this week not that I mind not that I mind of course in there
They will be wonderful
But usually it does for me most collab started like between two and four a.m. Oh, gosh
Oh
I really appreciate it. Well, thank you. Thank you for playing with me. It was super fun
I'm gonna do something again. I know we gotta we gotta plan something. Oh my gosh. That was so fun. Okay
Well guys, please check out um fua her information is pinned in my chat
And I think my information is pinned in her chat
Give her some love chucker or follow a sub whichever you desire
She is a lovely little kitty cat with cute cats herself
And and and shame same for shame. Oh my god shame shame me
Hahaha
Save for she be guys go go. They're not on twitch. But when they're not on twitch yet
Yes, but I'll let you watch the get twitch. Yep, but uh go go to their youtube
I know you guys go to my youtube uh to subscribe to my channel. So that means you have a youtube account go go subscribe to she be
Ah cat just popped up
Oh, yeah, that's that's tama. He's my tts
That's amazing. They shamed him. They shamed him
That's just like jump scared me. Thank you so much. I'll let you go get some rest. I'm probably gonna
Uh, probably gonna keep going just like and do my own thing for a little bit. Yeah
Have fun. It was so fun hanging out. Bye. Who is the sweetest? Bye
All right
We're just here
By ourselves
Let me close the game go back to the bedroom
Why is my
Feelings my body is showing
That was weird
Oh look the chat's working again. That's nifty
Can I can I move the chat over?
There we go. Oh cool
That's like super slow though. I don't like this chat widget
Full it is super nice. She's really sweet
Um, I remember we talked for like a long time like just over discord about stuff
And um, it was really cool. We actually have a lot in common. So it was really nice hanging out with her
She's super sweet. I'm happy that she could um guide me in the right direction
Because I'm she thinks she she says she's not good at those games
But she keeps saying all green means this blue means this and I'm like, oh, yeah, that's right because I can't forget
I'm not good at puzzles. But that was um, that was really fun to play
I would love to play that with you guys at some point
Maybe it could mod it to have more people
And then we do like rounds if you if you die you can't move forward
I don't know some sort of like half dead tourney. It's only like two bucks a game. So it's pretty cool
Um, yeah, she was big braining that she really was
I think she was saying she was garbage to make me feel better
I don't mind though. Um, I might try to stream again today later. Um, possibly
uh
Possibly, um, hoonie pop on house of blue
Uh on paywalls
Uh, no no pink egg. Just just vibes
So I'll try to do that. Um, probably not 4 p.m. Probably hold on. Let me look at the schedule
Let me see your time
Because I want to get some recording in I want to finish an asmr recording
um
But I also want to take a nap because I I've been I didn't go to sleep till 3 a.m
And
Then I woke up again because fia fia would need to use the bathrooms because because I sleep right next to her
She's right by my face. So show me out and I'll wake up
Um, let me see anybody
I want to make sure if anybody did though knows no. Okay, cool. Just want to make sure
Let me look at the schedule
I have to sign back in
Stay locked in
Oh
Okay
Okay, Azura is not streaming today. So I'll actually probably do it
At 8 p.m. Eastern time. I like kind of doing it at um
At later times house of blue just so I can get some stuff done. Um
But yeah, I'll do that 8 p.m. Eastern time. I'll play some hoonie pop and uh, just just vibe, you know
I
Drove five hours and stayed up for streaming past the photo job fun. Yeah fun. Uh, yeah, normal normal blue blue site time
Which is seven or eight. So we'll do we'll do eight. Um
I'm gonna go to sleep
I'm so tired
It's only I I I would have been fine. But since I was up streaming till 12 30
And then I was talking to you guys about house of blue stuff
Um, and then I was doing some other stuff on discord for another collab
I also have to set up my stream schedule. You know, I'm gonna be on stream
I'm an all right. I see in a moment because I know I see streaming
But uh, let's do my schedule right now. What do you guys want me to do next week?
I have a schedule
with
So my only
My manager manager messages me as I'm about to fall asleep. Um
Because feeding fia took a bit last night and
I only have like a collab. I have a collab of Rui, Aya and uh alien or Ali
uh next friday
but um
Oh, where'd the where'd the chat go? Where'd you guys go? Let me push this over here
Yep
There you go
Which Aya um
Where hold on. Let me look at there. I can't find everybody's stuff
What's what's their name?
Aya
Yeah, I was invited to a collab with with a couple of indies. I don't know them very well
But I'm branching out Aya Nari. Yeah, that's their name and Rui the panda girl be reviewed and then alien mixture
who I
Have not met before
So I hope it'll be fun. Usually I do a lot of research on people because I'm a weirdo
so um
Oh, I I don't know. I I uh, I haven't had the chance. So maybe I'll creep
New friends new friends new cute girls. Yeah
Let's go
Yeah
um
And it makes you it's pretty cool. Okay, cool. Yeah
Yeah, I'm very shy because uh, I'm
I'm used to I'm trying to branch out
And get to know more people. So I hope I can get to know more some cool some cool peeps
um
Don't forget guys also azura's birthday donathan is on saturday next saturday
Not this upcoming saturday. It's on the 24th. So
Make sure you guys have cleared your schedules for that
And I make sure it's hilarious and it's a nice singing voice. Oh, we'll get along. Okay, cool. Yeah friendship
We I remember we've we've been in a discord chat to prepare for stuff
and
I remember we're doing genital jousting in the oh my god. They're just posting germa memes
um
And I almost started bursting out laughing during stream because I went to glint at discord to look at the password that uh
that um
Fua sent me
and uh
I saw alien mixture said boob morning breasty
What's a funny
Gift and that made me crap out crack out crack. I can't even talk. There's so many germa memes
Everything's germa
Um, that's funny
Uh, so it's it's really cool. I was learning inari made um, uh
their own
model and stuff very talented
Rui is really cool. I remember we reviewed her for um
What's it called?
we reviewed her for
the
Design thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
We fine. I hope so. I feel I feel like I get nervous guys
I get nervous. Hi tomo
um
Let's see
Azur is playing hades on thursday, so I probably won't play hades on that day
Oh, there's a asmr train on sunday, but I can't stream on sundays
You know gotta save it for the lord um
Or should I play I don't know
I still need to I can't play anything with a controller
Because I have no controllers
None of my controllers work. Oh vampires suck. Yes. We got to do that. So I'll do that for monday
Oh my god, sometimes
Sometimes I wish I could show you the schedule, but sometimes I wish strawnee would just put in um
For her block
just like her time
Uh, because she just takes up usually a whole because you know strawnee just like endurance streams a lot social take up the whole entire day
And then like I'll just try to wedge myself in there
I wish you would just put like endurance stream and just the block so it doesn't take up everything
This is so funny. Um
Let me do this. I'll do
4 p.m. Watch along. No, I don't want to I also can't click on stuff because strawnee stuff is in the way
she be
member monday
member
Watch along
Vampires suck. I'm so excited to watch this
I watched uh, not another teen movie the other day and it was so funny
Let me put this out 4 p.m
To 6 p.m
Um
It means doing
An asmr on thursday, so maybe I'll do asmr on thursday and she's doing it in members asmr
I need ideas for members asmr. I haven't done any members asmr. Maybe I'll do that for next week
Be cactus
What's the dinner for member monday? That's a great question
I'll have to tell you what I'm feeling what I'm feeling in the mood for on sunday
Yes, I remember van I remember watching vampires suck with people that I went to church with which was like
We're like, yeah, let's see this movie because vampires are demonic
And they deserve to be made fun of and so and we were laughing at it so hard
Evil witch asmr that'd be fun because a lot of you guys seem to like the um
the uh
The the wood bowl stuff. I I love that trigger because I came across it
um, I I follow a lot of asmr artists just like on my normal account my my alts um
Because I love asmr. I've always loved asmr since like heather feather like how many years ago and um,
so I'll get I'll get uh
I'll get
Like idea triggers from that like to doing your makeup like I had no ideas and then I like to watch this girl called
Um pomo and she did a doing my lady's makeup
She's like a lady's maid or something and I was like, oh, that's pretty cool vampire girl. That'd be cool
That'd be cool. Maybe like a like a vampire
Themed week should we have a summer ween?
Summer ween week. Oh, yeah, we're doing it. We're doing it summer ween. Okay. I already know what game i'm gonna play
She be for tuesday
I
Wait, which one is this game? I just got a new game that I wanted to play
um
I got the second suckers for love game
Or is it that's it called sucker for love
Date to die for yes, and it's you just you pretty much just date baphomet
I
Yeah, because a full full one just came out. All right, so we'll do that
6 p.m
Off to find a witchy outfit
Um strani is doing a member script writing at 4 p.m. So I'll I'll take emi's slot
Um, oh, yeah, she's uh
Emie's doing a collab with uh, rui lapifi and elia still aria. Oh sick. That's awesome
At 1 p.m. So I'll take I'll take her 6 p.m. Slot
I I move around my schedule to accommodate people because like it's not fun when we all overlap and you want to watch us do things
you know
um
and
Yeah, I think that would be I think that would be pretty like I try to accommodate everybody
Just so like I don't want to overlap with like people if I don't have to that's why
I sort of kind of don't have this most super consistent schedule because like
um
sometimes
Like I know people will want to watch strani stream but also watch me too
um
and then or like
If like
Some things going on. Yeah on like I'll be the when we get new girls in gen 2
I'll probably the first one to change my time because I'll stream at any time
I just I I don't know. I'm just uh
Yeah, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm I'm too fucking nice for my own good. Uh, so then I want to do wedding witch
I love wedding witch. Um, I used to just no life wedding witch. Uh, we'll do that at 6 p.m
On wednesday, um
Strani's doing a block ups campaign. Oh shit
Let's do a witchy themed
And then and then I'll do my ASMR
And then the pin pals that watch me can go watch emmy's members asmr stream afterwards
And then azur is playing hades at nine. We love that
Yeah, like I try again I'm part of a business I try to people people think I'm just gonna like
Be a bitch the entire time and just do my own thing. No, I'm gonna I'm a team player
I've always been a team player
Okay, let's do she be
Okay, we'll make the homeless ASMR another day
I have enough you guys think I don't have an outfit for that. I have an outfit for that
I'll dress up like a witch. Um
Witch captures you
ASMR
I think I might make a little cool graphic
I
Think I might make a like a summer ween week graphic
And I can just boil you in a pot. Yeah, okay, and then a so 4 p.m. Vampire suck
Uh
4 p.m. Tuesday suckers for love day to die for 6 p.m. Wednesday wedding witch
4 p.m
Thursday ASMR witch captures you
ASMR role play then I've done a little jousting on friday and then I have the collab
With um for azur as donathan
um
Oh, emi's playing into the pit. I've been watching markiplier play that
Maybe at 8 p.m. I'll play something
Because strani has a members
movie
She puts she always overlaps her members stuff with for my slot. Um
But then again like she she's australian time
um
8 p.m. I'll stream on saturday. I don't know what to stream saturday. What's another witchy themed thing
That um, I what time is the witch ASMR normal time 4 p.m
The only time that's different actually is just um wednesday, which is the wedding witch game
Um, what should it what sort of witchy or halloween themed thing should I do for saturday that doesn't require a controller
Because I need to get a controller. I might have to put it on throne because I paid my bills and I have no money
Hand cam drink mixing brewing potion. Oh, that's a good idea. Oh my god. That's perfect actually. Thank you
Uh she be
Hand cam
Mixing
Or
Alternatively, I could dress up as a witch for the ASMR and have a hand cam alongside the ASMR
Which would you prefer?
Would you prefer hand cam with ASMR or would you prefer its own hand cam?
Because I think it'd be like kind of like nice visual for you guys to see me like mixing stuff
Like mixing the the wood soup, you know
And I can still mix drinks
Yeah, okay, we'll do that. We'll do that. We'll do that. We'll do that. I'll I'll make it a combined thing
Uh discard
Oh
With hand cam I'll have to think of drinks to mix because I don't drink alcohol guys. I really don't um
Or like I just make I don't I'll have to find stuff to make
Um, but yeah, I like I love visual aids and ASMR like they make and I can do like
Finger flutters and stuff and be like and then hopefully I get that um, I get that
Uh
Camera clamp so then it'll be a lot easier for me to do
um
like top down
Uh webcam record because I just used my like c920 webcam. I don't think I'm gonna try to get any webcam anytime soon
Because I think it's fine
I don't really think I need a camera. It's not like
I should find what those really
crazy twitch thoughts use that have like 4k hd, but my computer can't even run that so
That wouldn't even work
Please be cruel during the ASMR. Oh, of course. I've captured you to eat you. There will be more involved
I I've just decided
The drinks for the brewer gamer subs. Oh, oh my god
This is why this is why we're talking this is why we're having a great time
Oh my god, like oh like this is why I talk to you guys
Because you guys have great ideas and I want to give you what you guys want
You can use the international bartender association for some content cocktails. Oh, okay
I want to put like I want to put like um like the little sparkly stuff in it
The sparkly like so make it look like potions
Cutting veggies ASMR. I could make a stew that I put you guys in um
But I think I'm gonna stick with drink mixing. Yeah edible glitter. I'll buy some edible glitter
I don't know where I'll have to order on amazon
Uh, I have a potion bottle from one of my my uh renaissance fair cosplays
um
I also have a bunch of witchy stuff
Because I'm a pagan so that'll work out. Um, I think me and emmy actually have the same like
Uh, what's it called tapestry that she's used for a hand cam before maybe I'll do a little bit of tarot too
I could have a tarot reading stream on saturday for hand cam
Hmm
I might monetize that though and like because people kind of kept spamming me for stuff
So I might have to be like, oh if you donate like ten dollars, you'll get a reading
um
That could be fun. Would you guys be okay with that if I pay all that just because
Uh, it
It might sound stupid to you, but it is emotionally taxing to read cards for people
and um
A bunch of people kind of just I realized spammed a bunch uh of their questions
And when I didn't answer them they would keep spamming
um, so I might
I might pay all that
And then it'll also help me keep better track of who to read
Um, I do take it seriously tarot isn't a joke to me either is like spell stuff
Um
So I could make a spell jar
Oh
You know what I think I'll make a spell jar too. We'll do some tarot make a spell jar together
Um
Yeah, helps with filtering again. I hate paywalling stuff, but like just for again filtering purposes
Uh
Yeah, okay
We'll do that
So saturday is that's azura's birthday donathan though. I would hate to take away from azura's birthday donathan
So I might
Do
The asmr on saturday
Instead
Or I can do wedding
I could do the wedding witch
On saturday because I would have to make that at 8 p.m. And then I would have to make
Oh
Because I don't want to like take away like profit wise from azura's birthday donathan. I would prefer you guys to support her on that day
um
I'm gonna do the wedding witch on saturday at 8 p.m
Because that's that's fine. That's fine. Yeah, that's fine. We'll do at 6 p.m. Eastern time
Um
Maybe I'll do for like five bucks not ten bucks
Uh, yeah, that sounds better
Don't don't ask why my thing popped up
Favorite power-up and wedding witch by the way, I can't remember everybody wedding witch in like three months
Sudden hood we in the hood like a baby. Oh
a baby
Nope, that makes my boobs bigger. I remember I was like playing with this toggle and I'm like, I don't see anything different
And then only recently I realized that it makes my booba bigger
Um, oops, I accidentally typed in a bunch of numbers on the thing
Okay, so what do you guys think summer wean
So 4 p.m
We're watching on august 19th. We're doing vampire suck member watch along
I might do something else that day because nobody streams on mondays
Only me and strawnee and mercy stream on mondays
Um
So I might stream
after that
too
After watching vampire suck. Maybe I'll I might do a gorilla. We'll see or before
vampires suck. Maybe a gorilla
I heard a wedding. Oh, we're just talking about my schedule spooky karaoke
Hmm
That would be interesting
I could do a gorilla spooky arch uh archived karaoke
Hmm
Hmm, maybe another time shibooty
All right, so we're gonna
Yeah, the spooky got that is super on brand though. You're right. I could have shibooty come back
Frick
Oh
Okay, would you prefer
karaoke
On wednesday at 6 p.m. Or a witchy hand cam or I read tarot or making spell jars
And making spell jars
What do you guys think?
So
emo girl karaoke
Wednesday the 21st or which hand cam on the 21st?
Which hand cam okay, which hand cam
Witchy hand cam on a weekend
I can't do it on the weekend
because
I
Would prefer to do something a little simple and casual during azura's birthday donathon
And I don't stream on Sundays because that's my dedicated time off
For the lord
Wednesday's fine
Hard choice hand cam Wednesday should be okay, so we'll stick with the hand cam
I'll do the spooky karaoke another time
Maybe I'll save spooky karaoke for halloween because I want to do some actual like fun stuff during halloween
I want to do like literally every day of halloween or every day of october like something spooky like how
Game grumps has like ghoul grumps for the whole month. I kind of want to do a spooky shibi month
um
And I just like dress up and stuff that'll be fun
I like I like to make events out of it
October is right around the corner exactly
September just should be taken out although september has my birthday. So oh boomi. You just stomped on my boob. Hi handsome boy
Hi
Hi, what's up big man?
Hi, oh
Here you can go back
Boomi's standing on my lap and on my desk at the same time. He's such a big cat
You such a big boy
Why did you get so big? Oh, you like the pets
You like the headpats. You do like the headpats. Don't you big boomi? Oh, you love the headpats
The headpats galore
mm-hmm
The other fail holidays. Yeah, I have a special stuff planned for christmas
too
depending I don't know if I'm
My family might be spending christmas with Salem
Um, because usually usually I'm alone for the holidays
Uh, because my family doesn't really like do anything
They're they're too busy. My parents are busy people. My parents once I left they're just like
We could do whatever we want. We have a life now
Um
So, yeah
uh
We'll see I'll see if I'm hanging out with Salem in her family
On christmas. I know I'm probably we usually do like a friendsgiving
Um
I also still need to talk to Salem about doing the podcast like we still have to get that
So I have to make her like a v2 bottle and all that stuff or like a png youtuber
um
I got a lot of I got a lot of stuff planned guys got a lot of stuff going on
Um
Holidays with us and viola then yeah precisely essentially
It just sucked. I like I try to leave my house around the holidays though because like
Like I do love spending time with you guys. I remember last year as Rina. I literally just stayed
And just celebrated everything with
I did the like um
the uh
pagan origins of Halloween and pagan origins of christmas and the
uh
pagan origins of Thanksgiving
Um
And I did those little slideshows. That was pretty fun
Actually in like or like what actually happened during Thanksgiving. Um, but we'll see
Uh, but you guys are the people I love so like well, I'll see I'll just see how it is
I'll see how it is. Um
100% obviously my birthday september 20 100%
Uh, usually we don't celebrate friends giving with all the girly pops on Thanksgiving
So we're probably we can probably spend maybe I'll do a cooking stream for Thanksgiving
Look at me thinking so far ahead Christmas. I definitely want to you know, I already told you guys stuff for Halloween
um
Usually I go
To like a spooky spooky fair. There's usually like spooky fairs in my area
Um, or like haunted houses
Or like haunted amusement parks
As new england loves that shit. Um
So I'll probably do something like that. Maybe I could do like a live vlog. I don't know
I've never done a live vlog before. I probably accidentally stalks myself
Um, I'll probably maybe I'll do live vlogs a little bit later in
My tenure at bealer. Wait. I just I like I like thinking a lot. I like I like thinking
Um, all right, let's let's read icy. Let's uh, so okay. Let me let me tell you the schedule
So this is a schedule for next week
clear your plans
uh
You know what maybe on
Maybe our dinner. What do vampires eat?
Eat something red
like marceline for for our our uh
Our movie dinner date
uh august 19th
4 p.m
She be member watch along vampires suck
august
20th tuesday
4 p.m. She be sucker for love date to die for
Wednesday the 21st of august
6 p.m
witchy hand cam reading tarot and making spell jars
Thursday the 22nd
Is asmr witch captures you with hand cam
friday the 23rd
um
Is the genital jousting collab which will be funny with rui aya and ali
And then saturday is azura's birthday donathan and we're play wedding witch
Yep, yep
I'll be fun
It'll be actually funny if we played sucker for love date to die for on her birthday because it'll be like we're romancing azura
Um, and then sunday's off. Okay. Does that sound good? Yeah
I have some spaghetti maybe some spaghetti
Some good spaghetti would be actually that's a pretty good idea
Uh, there's probably I won't be surprised if I stream tomorrow. I don't know why I had tomorrow
I didn't put anything for tomorrow. I'll be honest with you
um
I'll probably maybe I'll do like an elden ring gorilla tomorrow
Actually, no, I can't I don't have a fucking controller. Wait, is my controller still not working it started working
It started charging but then it stopped
Yeah, it's just
That's shit not working anymore homie. I tried another controller too
I'm wondering if it's the cable
Because it's saying it keeps flashing orange like it's charging but then it never turns on
I don't know what that means. It blinks twice and then another twice
We could do a fun zastu tomorrow. Maybe I kind of talk enough
Did you set a day off to get groceries and get controller from your paw?
My dad said he wouldn't give me his controller because it says he has one. Actually, no, he has two controllers
They're both custom made my dad is a scuff controller and some other custom made controller. Um
Because my dad plays a lot of lots a lot of call of duty
um
I hope I wonder if he's gotten any better
Uh
But yeah
Yeah, every streamer isn't assumed zatsu usually be zatsu for like 30 minutes to an hour before I play a game
Guys, I might come back later today. I just need to go to sleep
and then wake up feed fia and then
Hop on I need to go to sleep wake up feed fia finish
I just need to finish recording that damn asmr. So I can give you a new asmr video
and then
um
Over I'll stream a little bit perhaps if I feel better
Because I'm a kind of a little bit dizzy because that game kind of made me a little bit motion sick
um
And then I also need to do the script writing for october because I said told just told strani
I would rewrite the script but now I'm actually wondering if I have time for that
um, who knows
I probably no I'll have time tomorrow. Maybe I set aside some uh saturday for script writing
Maybe actually yeah, I might maybe I'll keep that for because I want to record
um
My audios for patreon because I still haven't recorded september yet
uh
I'm gonna rewrite october
I'm gonna rewrite october completely. I'm gonna do a totally different theme. I'm gonna make it halloween themed
for each um
day
And uh, so you guys can tell me I'll probably tweet out
September is very close. Yeah, exactly. That's why I want to I want to get on top of that
um
So maybe I'll keep tomorrow open just so I can record
Also, I was gonna record yesterday, but there's a stupid fucking storm and I didn't feel good
Yeah, I think I'm gonna put that controller on throne
Uh
Yeah, I think I I need to start organizing my time better
Like I do like the calendar on here because it helps remind me what I'm doing
But I needed I think I'm gonna put a cat like an actual calendar calendar
That I can have above my desk on my throne
So I just remember what the fuck I'm doing because I forget all the time
um
Is that the first time I swore this stream? I don't even know
Uh, but yeah
I had some keynote ideas. Thank you. I'm gonna
I'm gonna practice
I haven't written anything like that in a long time
When I say a long time it was a couple months ago. I remember I started writing a
I'm probably just gonna look at one of the scripts stroney
Stroney stroney wrote me before and kind of follow that formula because I prefer how her her writing style is
Um, it's all gonna be dom. It's all dom. It's gonna be dom
I'm not gonna fuck around with the stupid like
Kind of dom shit like I'm gonna do it dom and I'm not gonna do the really crappy dom that the other guy wrote
Because yeah
Because I just I want to do like dom werewolf girl. I would love to do dom vampire girl
Dom, I don't know ghost girl
Dom slime girl
Like that would be fun
Got to yeah, I've never been there. Uh, it's what is it? Is it r slash gwa? I don't know what it is. Um
I'm a city city of dom because uh
The the script I want to just literally give you just like a full dom thing
The thing is though patreon also doesn't like dommy mommies
Uh, just like they don't like what emmy and ic do
And then you have they have to dance around it. They just released a new thing
Um, I think it was like a month ago. I remember sending the the update to stroney like they don't like
Mommy related stuff. So I I can't be like
Mommy related
Or like step mommy stuff because I would have written like step mom does this or blah blah blah does this
Um
But I like I have to you do have to kind of skirt stuff with dom and you can't be like abusive
Um, it's it is really difficult
Um with their how their yeah, exactly the payment processors. Um, I do have like two
Scripts I want to read for blue website. Um, and those will be paywalls behind the five dollar
Um
That are kind of I've said I've yanked from
Suggestions on a certain basket weaving board
um
But yeah
Wait, what is this?
Oh
That tweet's actually doing pretty good
I'm the hello kumars and feet enjoyers tweet
It's so funny. Um, I'll be honest with you. I should show you guys. I look my model is way darker on
Stream and I don't know what is the brightness on my displays, but I'm a lot darker
I accidentally made myself a lot darker than I wanted because I can take a picture of my model right now
And I'm actually a lot lighter than what comes up
Let me I'll take a picture for you guys
Can I
Can I get that stupid? Okay
And this is this is what my skin tone is supposed to be I I'll be honest with you I kind of made myself darker than I
But I I don't know how to fix it
I'll post that when you guys can see
But I realize when no, I'm not gonna be even guys. I'm trying to be close to my own personal like skin tone
I'm not that dark as my model currently
um
But I realize in like thumbnails and stuff. I remember I was like wait
Huh wait a second
That's not the skin tone I wanted but I'm like, uh, it doesn't really matter
I was requested for it, but uh you sent me a script
Okay
Yeah, they don't like yeah, they will
That's a good point color is hard here
I'll just I'll literally post it on my alt right now and you guys can go see what my skin tone is supposed to be
I
Realize my model comes off a lot darker on stream
Versus on my screen
IDK why
What my brightness is set up
You
There we go, which we did that. Um, I like how I said I was gonna raid I see like an hour ago. Um
She be model be like
Do you want me to send it again? It's okay. I'll find it. Um guys
I don't really look at mirrors too much anymore. I'll be honest with you
So I prefer people you could just like at me
And I'll try to hopefully get doesn't get like filtered out. Um, I see she's doing a watch along
Probably not a good rate is she is it a
What?
What day is it
She's watching Yu-Gi-Oh
1990 is that a members is she is that a members thing?
Or do I at you dm no you just do at she be as of
I had
Um, just like literally at me on twitter not like dm me you can't dm me
Do you only stream on ty? Yes, I do only stream on ty on tube you
um
I hope you look well that'll never happen in terms of that'll be anybody who uses patreon or at the whims of patreon and the payment processors
so
Um, no, it's open. Okay. No, no, I'm still gonna read. I see because that was my plan. I'm not gonna
I don't care if she's doing a watch along or not
Um, yeah, why don't you guys go watch Yu-Gi-Oh? That's like peak. I don't know what you guys are talking about
All right
And then once I get uh, eventually we'll come back to hitman abs solution. I just need a controller
Uh
It's a really funny thumbnail. Oh my god
All right. Oh my god, my tummy hurt. I need to go grocery shopping for actual food
Could take a screenshot of the script too, you know the thread of it all would be easier to read
Well, I don't have a threat. No, it's like somebody linked me something from well not linked me in particular
I was just being a creep uh somebody linked a script bin
Of a here. I can I can literally read you what it is
Um, because I don't care. I'm not I'm not gonna keep surprises. So there's one
That is
Uh, your bossy girlfriend makes you her bitch female for male
And then the other one is
somebody linked
My voice is your sex life
And it's
It's lily about a girl who is like a streamer
Who tells you like you have to be obsessed with me and just degrades you the entire time. Um
Oh
Yeah
Does that make sense? Are we all are we all at an agreement here? Are we all good?
Are we all having a great time?
Make sense. All right
Mind take a phone pick and not take a screen grab. I took a phone pick because on my screen
It doesn't it's the brightness
I don't know what the brightness like it doesn't make a difference on if I screen grab it's still going to screenshot as a darker tone
Oh my god, I don't know. I don't know how to explain it to you guys
My screen brightness
Is changes that
Yeah
But do you but do you see what I mean though like I'm I'm supposed I might just color pick
Because none of my colors are accurate
Um these displays I've had for like years, but I don't really care that much about replacing them anytime soon
Uh, I have more other priorities. I'd rather replace like my computer and paying off my debt
Than getting new displays
That have more accurate color. They're just like asus ones. They both have the same brand
But for some reason they're both the two screens. I'll match them exactly for the settings
For the screen settings and they're also still different from one another like one is darker than the other
Sometimes let the 10 I know I need it. I need to get rid of the 1070
Um, yeah, I know you guys will probably freaking cry because I'm technically supposed to be whiter
I actually I might I might color grab
I'm like colors in my that on my model and make them more accurate. I don't fucking care. I just like
I'm just I'm just irritated that it does that
Because then I realized this stuff is still inaccurate and I'm just like what the fuck
The screens are very inconsistent. Yeah
But yeah, you guys see like, uh, I'm sorry. I'm not supposed to be that dark. I'm just gonna I'm just supposed to be tan
I'm
I'm just supposed to be tan
Because I'm not that dark. I'm I'm literally like the color that in that screen grab is what I am
Oh, no, it's like the color in that screen like you guys seen the picture I posted on my alt
That's I I'm actually a little bit lighter
Because I darkened up the photo a little bit. Um, when I edited it up
To make my butt smaller. I mean what?
Um, but are we good? Are we all agreed? I want to read. I see now
Oh, my stomach hurts
Are you oh, oh another thing another thing because I know people are gonna do this or I know somebody's gonna say this
Oh, why is she be?
Butting in to emmy's niche with all the witchy stuff one emmy doesn't give a fuck
I know she doesn't
Two she could have a whole day or a week where she does dom stuff, you know, it's fine
We we it's this is a summer ween. It's a funny event
I want to do something cool
Yes, I know her thing is she's the witchy one. I know she's the one with the book and doing the spells and haba dabba dabba
But
I want to do something fun
I want to have a themed week like a spirit week that you would have in school
And I'm also IRL a pagan so it's kind of cool to show you guys parts of my own
belief system my culture
Um, and it's just fun and it's fun fun games, you know
All right, um
They're not gonna be able to handle October. I just like I just know I'm just like I'm just I'm I'm punching
the one dude that's gonna
Shit up stuff really fast
You know what I don't like I don't like when people follow me back multiple times and it's like unfollow and follow me
I'll follow and follow me
Expecting me to follow them
Because somebody just did that while I've been sitting here for the last hour
It just did it a bunch of times and I'm probably gonna block them
Stop
I'll it'll it'll be one. Yes. I don't feel like getting one guide about that stupid shit. So I'm just gonna say it now
um
None of us
Really care. You know who I want to do Dom stuff Azura because she's really good at it and you guys don't even know
We I remember we talked until like a discord call for like three hours
Just me and her and she was like talking about stuff with me
um
And I'm like, what do you know about like Dom stuff? She was like, oh, I know a little bit
I would read stuff and then I was like, oh, give me an example and then she would just like say stuff to me
And I'm like what?
What do you want to do you want to switch job? I'm kidding. Um
Uh guys, it's not that guys when I bring by the way when I bring up something that might be like a mild
Irritant to me. You guys don't all have to yes man me like I noticed that's a thing
I'll be like I'll make it like sometimes stuff hasn't even happened yet and people be like I can't believe
These shitty human beings. Fuck them. I can't believe it like I remember
I did when I tweeted that I was gonna be tan
um
I was like don't whine about it
Or like because I don't give a crap and then people are like, oh my god
The people who are whining right now. I'm like, no, nobody's whining. I'm just saying if you do like you don't
Yeah, you should be a terrified of a zero. I know you care about me
It's great
but like
You don't have to shit on people that don't exist yet when they happen then you can shit on them. Okay, but like
I I honestly generally don't get like
Any hate as much as I did when I first started and that's fine like I get the occasional like troll that's like
N word and that's all they got but like otherwise I'm good
You don't have to apologize. You're fine
Stop it before it happens. I I understand
um
But almost I almost realized sometimes that people's reaction to what I'm saying almost makes it like that feeds the trolls more
Because like if I go into a girl's thread and she's talking about
how people
Like to f people who whine for changing
The characters. I don't know fucking animal for example
And people are the the thing like oh fuck those people
I'm gonna be like I'm gonna go troll and act like one of those people right now because I'm an asshole because that's how I am
um
Me having been a yes man to a previous streamer who frequently ranted because he turned me into a people
Please
principle sweating. Yeah, you don't have to be a yes man to me. I like again. I like your honest opinions
I like when you have a conversation with me. I love the transparency that we have in this relationship
I talk to you about my schedule. I find out what you guys like. I tell you what I don't like
Um, please never take anything. I say personally by the way if I like tease you or bully you or do this or that
Or if I like scold you in the chat, please don't internalize it. I don't fucking hate you
I'm just giving you a warning by the way
um
If you want you to troll her I get enough of that
Honestly, the fact that I didn't get a catalog bait thread when I posted my sus thing yesterday
Was a travesty to be honest with you. I was expecting to be shat on
But I didn't it didn't happen. Maybe it'll happen in a couple days. Maybe someone's gonna type it up right now. Stop it
Stop it
Stop it. Okay, but you guys um
Yeah, balance is important
Wait, do you have zebness in your name? Oh, I fucking love
Organization 13 365 days or 360 whatever the fuck that game is called. It's one of my favorite games because I love more lucha
I'm manifesting manifesting the trolls manifesting them
No, I'm kidding. Um, no, honestly, uh, I have had a lot
Like besides in my maros and like my legit maros, I don't really get anything
Like I don't get people like adding these stupid shit. I get the occasional troll marrow. You know what?
Let's I'm gonna check my maros right now. Let's see. Let's see what we got
I haven't looked at my maros in a couple days
Let's see how many how many oh my god, I have 550 maros. Um
Um
There's a stream idea I would like to see you have a collab with emmy
Do an introduction to esoterrorism together you and tarot emmy on witchcraft
You can talk about super downs. That'd be cool
That'd be cool if we did like a little collab together. Um, like a little slideshow
I know I know emmy and I think even mercy are like kind of new to it. So
Um
I kind of don't want it because I'm very
I won't lie to you. I'm kind of a gatekeeper when it comes to that because I don't want to like
um
People to get the information and just start doing stupid shit because they don't take it seriously and then they accidentally hurt themselves
Um
But yeah
Uh, it's okay to be yourself k famous overrated
You
What
Why did someone just come into my maros and just expose a bunch of people for being males
For like this this streamer is a male the streamer was a signed male. Why would you I don't okay?
What
Hey she be can you start doing squats so your ass gets fatter fatter? Uh, I'm trying
Hey she be talking about collabing with the youtubers
Okay, I'll check the person out
Madam you make me oni
A little nice little tribute. I'll look at that
You did it four times good. Whoa, someone wrote me a whole thing
I have some help from some other harlots and vealer fans to read the bible. I'm dyslexic
What
Oh, why would you
I'm sorry the structure that sentence totally threw me off. I I didn't I missed I messed up
Over six minutes. Let's don't why would I okay? We got some some number recommendations. Thank you
All right, you're giving me a real thing for chalky women sure whatever
So funny when people call me like compare me to food
Um
See
Sorry, it's been a while
Oh
Someone got a cat that's adorable
Someone loves me and is kissing me a bunch. Oh my god. This is so
I thought there was a character limit. Oh, they're a verified user
That's why they were able to bypass the character limit. Holy crap
All the voices you do are amazing. Oh, thank you
Mind you are doing great and trash loves you very much with a lovely little cat pucks link
Hey sheebie, I didn't see a vibe with me option on your house of blue streams
It allows viewers to also enjoy the vibes along with you
What?
Wait, you can do that
You
Mercy might be able to help set that up
What the frick all right, I'll figure mercy does it
What the hell
Damn, all right, I'll figure that out. Love the non outfit and voice combo. Oh, thank you
And the rest is just really bad
I had horrible stuff for house of blue when bb was streaming that I cannot read out loud
Forgive me sister bb for I've sinned. I worked my way through college by by showing my body and dancing around a pole for tides to pay my fees
Okay, cool cool cool. Whoa snap
Hey madame, can you quickly? No
I'm not saying that. I don't care. Don't worry. It's not a slur. It means I love you. No, I don't believe you
I don't believe you at all. What language is this? I'm googling it
Is that tag along
Oh
Yeah, Filipino. All right, mahal kita
Mahal kita hanam
Did I spell that right?
Did I pronounce that right?
I just didn't try. I don't trust that
To the safety cuckoo
Shout out to all my Filipino fans. You're a real one
Oh, I love how I knew it was tagalog. I'm impressive
Damn
I'm a real one
You can't believe she just said that
All right, um
All right. Yeah, see I haven't really had anything like trolling lately. So that's good
But I'm fine. I'm good
Oh my do you hear that? That was my collar bone that just popped my chest
Say a booby
Booby was that
His eyes were so big and then he looked at me and he like, you know how cats do a little cat kiss
Where they squint their eyes and close them slowly. That's what he did to me
Why are you so sweet? Oh, you're gonna make kitty kisses
Oh, why is your mouth open?
why
Sometimes he just stares at me with his mouth open
um
Well, yeah, does that make does that make sense is that
Me good and we agreed upon everybody post
a
The the nutting emote, you know what which emote that is in the chat the oh if you understand
If you understand listen if you if you're a great name, I'm sorry
Thank you perfect. I also just like telling you guys what to do and then you do it
It's really fun to see you put a you put the clown, you know what?
You put the clown
You're going you're you're out of town. All right
You put the clown you out of town
It's okay, they're just gone for a minute
I
Murder yeah, don't disobey. I don't I don't like brass. I am the brat
It's me
I'm him him him him him
I t b o y b b n o dollar sign. That's me. That's right
I am h i m the gen z m n m
That's me. That's right. So I like that that song's a banger to sing
It is a you know a brat summer
as per charlie xcx
um
I listened to that because I didn't know what brat summer was. I've only I'm only on the vtuber sphere
I'm not in the normie sphere
So I looked up the songs from the album and I'm like one of them which is about her just like doing crack
I'm just like why is this a banger?
Why is this you know, we're back in the days of glorifying drug use and songs and mainstream media
Have you seen bb no money and drag for his music videos? No, what?
Google bb no money drag
Images
What the hell
Wait, is that him?
He literally looks like what's her face. I forget what that queen's name is. I don't remember that's that's pretty cool
tb gamersops addiction song
That'd be pretty sick. Wait, what are the lyrics to that? It's uh, what's the charlie xcx song charlie xcx
Brat is it 360?
Brat
Album
Is it 360? Yeah, I think it's 360
lyrics
No
Oh, yeah bump in that bump in that bump in that
Bump in that gamer subs gamer subs gamer I'm just snorting gamer subs
That song is literally a banger though
365 you mean the bathroom if you bump in that
I
Think boomie just farted it smells
You're stinky
Fia farted twice last night next to my face
And then I regretted having her close to my face
What was I doing? I was gonna raid icy. I keep getting distracted and might have headphones in my ears and nothing's even playing
I can't I can't take it out. It's stuck in my hair
Have you heard the guess from that element? No
I don't listen to charlie xcx
The one time I went on tiktok to upload a tiktok that song came up
I'm like, this is kind of hard and then I realized what it was about and I'm like should I be listening to this
Please don't redirect the blame to boomie, but I can't then my cats fart boomie. You're so cute though right now
Why are you so cute?
He's sitting in the bed. He's sitting in a little bed behind me
Oh, I had to take a picture. Hold on. He's a handsome boy right now. I need to get him another bow tie
Oh my god, what a sultry gaze. Look at this. Hold on. I'm gonna post it
Boomies
Sultry gays
What the sassy paw out and the tucking the other paw in
That's pretty nice. Well, do you prefer lights on or off?
What
Yeah differences. Okay. Yeah, you guys also agree. I might change that I'll do that another day
Yeah
Do you guys see do you see the picture of boomie?
I put it on my uh, why do I look like I'm like
My eye was tweaking
Yeah, let's just so just a doctive look like I don't understand
Oh, now he went to sleep because he he laid his head down and closed his eyes
um
Does somebody photoshop a bow tie on to him or like a tie in a top hat or fedora
With his hand tipping it going malady. I don't know whatever you guys want
Um, I was supposed to end stream like such a long time ago. Okay. Bye guys
Bye hang out with icy for 15 more minutes. No for 30 more minutes for me
Because I don't have anybody else from raid. Bye
I'm going to bed